at this altitude this episode is brought
to you by four Sigma deck
you might remember four sig Matic for
their mushroom coffee which was created
by those clever Finnish founders and
when I first mentioned that coffee on
this podcast the products sold out in
less than a week it lights you up like a
Christmas tree which can be really
useful however recently I've been
testing the opposite side of the
spectrum a new product and that is their
reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my
day to get to sleep as you guys may know
longtime listeners at least I struggled
with insomnia for decades I have a
largely fixed that but still shutting
off my monkey brain has never been easy
still isn't easy very often and I found
reishi which have been fascinated by for
a few years now has been very very
effective and calming their old formula
however for sig Maddox old formula
included stevia and I like to avoid
sweeteners all sweeteners for a host of
reasons and I then just ping them and
asked hey guys I would love to
experiment with this and maybe actually
suggest it but I'd like a version
without sweeteners if you'd be open to
it if too much of a headache don't worry
and they are always game for
experimentation so they created a
special custom version without the
stevia without sweeteners now it is part
of my nightly routine their ratio elixir
comes in single serving packets which
are perfect for travel and in fact I'm
about to leave the country right now and
I have a packet in front of me that's
just gonna sit in the end of my carry-on
bag
you only need hot water and it mixes
very very easily here's some recommended
copy that they put in the read so I'm
gonna read it and I'll give you my take
quote a warning for those in the
experimental mindset reishi is strong
and bitter in parentheses like any great
medicine so if the bitterness is too
much I recommend trying it with honey
or nut milk such as almond milk and
quote so I'm gonna say no you should
suck it up and you should drink the tea
because it's not that bitter and maybe
you should take the advice of all
Chinese people when they're criticizing
young uns when they say boo and I'm sure
cool which means you're not able to eat
bitterness bitter is in many cases an
indication of things that help liver
detoxification and so on not saying
that's the case here but I've tested
this reishi lecture on family members on
friends everybody has liked it it's a
little bit earthy it's not that hard so
I would just say suck it up and know
don't put it in honey or nut milk or any
of that just drink the goddamn tea
it's delicious I think right if you like
puer that kind of stuff that type of tea
you're gonna dig it so just try it okay
back to then my read if you'd like to
naturally improve your sleep both on set
and quality I think naturally you might
just enjoy this ratio lecture without
any sweeteners it has organic reishi
extract organic fueled mint extract
organic rosehips extract organic Tulsi
extract and that's it no fancy stuff no
artificial whatchamacallit anything so
check it out go to four sigma tech comm
forward slash ferrous and get 20% off
this special batch I don't know if
they're gonna be making much more of
this since it was made specifically for
you guys so do me a favor and try it out
so that they continue to be open to
experimenting with me to create products
for you guys specifically check it out
for Sikkim addict that's fo you are SI
GMA TI c calm /e ferrous f e RR ISS and
get 20% off the special batch and you
must use the code Ferris
to receive your discount fer our ISS so
again go to 4 Sigma 2 comm forward slash
Ferris and then use code Ferris for 20%
off of this rare exclusive limited run
of reishi mushroom elixir for nighttime
routines without any sweeteners enjoy
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books man oh man do a lot of listeners
of this podcast and readers of mine love
fresh books to the extent that I ended
up meeting with the CEO not very long
ago why are they so popular well they
are the number one cloud accounting
software designed exclusively for
self-employed professionals that's many
of you and used by more than 10 million
people you can send invoices track your
time and get paid very very quickly
which suits the needs of a lot of
freelancers a lot of entrepreneurs and
beyond you can take pictures of receipts
you can link your credit card and debit
cards so all the things you buy
automatically appear in your fresh books
in the right category so on and so forth
makes taxes easy makes invoices easy
makes your life easier and also in fact
I'd recommend a PDF they didn't ask me
to read this part by the way they put
the other PDF a while back called
breaking the time barrier subtitle how
to unlock your true earning potential so
you can search for breaking the time
barrier a lot of people ask me how can I
get a 4-hour workweek with a service
business and the story in that ebook its
PDF is the short answer it's really
really good so I think you should also
check that out so breaking the time
error check it out but also why not test
out fresh books claim your 30-day
unrestricted free trial at fresh
ebooks.com forward slash tim and enter
tim ferriss
two hours in two S's in the how did you
hear about us section that sounds like
we're gonna get very little tracking
that's a lot of work but just go to
fresh books calm forward-slash tim and
try it out because it is a very good
product and i think you will find it
simplifies your life
enjoy
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is my job every episode to
deconstruct world-class performers
people who are excellent if not the best
at what they do in many many many
different fields and that scratchiness
is Tim Ferriss coming off of antibiotics
because I had some little gremlins
inside me that I brought back from the
Amazon that's a separate story in any
case my job deconstruct that many fields
and this particular episode we have a
wonderful guest Jack cornfield
Alice Walker calls Jack quote one of the
greatest spiritual teachers of our time
and what Jack trained as a Buddhist monk
in the monasteries of Thailand India and
Burma shortly thereafter becoming one of
the key teachers to introduce Buddhist
mindfulness practice to the West he is
taught meditation internationally since
1974 that's before I was even a glimmer
and my papa's ISO it's been teaching for
a very very long time and he has had a
profound and direct impact directly on
my life so I'm thrilled to finally have
him on the podcast to share our shared
history his incredible stories and the
practical tactics and very detailed
techniques that you can use and we dig
into all of that and you can also say hi
to him on the Internet at jack Kornfield
on twitter check it out Jack's history
just a little bit won't spend too much
time on it Jack co-founded the Insight
Meditation Society in Barre
Massachusetts with fellow meditation
teachers Sharon Salzberg has also been
on this podcast and Joseph Goldstein and
later the Spirit Rock Center in Whitacre
California which is where I did my first
silent retreat and we talked about that
he holds a PhD in clinical psychology
which is important to me and comes into
this conversation because he's a very
very diverse toolkit for dealing with
many different types of personal
challenges issues questions and so on
and is a father husband and activist his
books have been translated into 20
languages and sold more than a million
copies he is prolific his books include
and I pulled some of you for your
favorites a wise heart
that's number one and lamp in the
darkness a path with heart after the
ecstasy the laundry one of my favorite
book titled small time and his most
recent book no time like the present
subtitle finding freedom love and joy
right where you are he is quite possibly
the most purely compassionate human
being I've ever interacted with and
compassion isn't a word that I used very
much but Jack is unique and I'm thrilled
to give you a window into his story and
his teachings without further ado please
enjoy this wide-ranging conversation
with jack Kornfield
Jack welcome to the show
oh thank you Tim pleasure to reconnect I
have wanted to have you on the show for
some time now and you've had certainly a
tremendous impact on my life both
through your writing and through
firsthand in-person interaction which I
think we'll touch upon
but first I wanted to ask you a complete
non sequitur from that which is
something that our mutual friend Adam
Ghazali suggested I ask you about and
Adam for people who don't know him is an
incredible PhD MD neuroscientist based
at UCSF and he suggested that I ask you
about hang gliding and I have no idea
why he suggested that but I'm gonna
start there and if it doesn't go
anywhere we can we can change direction
but I figured we would just start with
that and then we're gonna rewind the
clock but why did he suggest I ask you
about hang gliding well it started many
years ago when I cross country with a
friend who had a hang glider and we
would stop periodically and go off
different hills and it was fantastic and
then I wanted to do paragliding and
started to learn it now because
everything is developed in paragliding
is like you know is a lot more official
you need a license which I don't have
but one of my favorite things is to
tandem paraglide and go off the top of
places like Grindelwald in in
switzerland where you can take the ski
lift up to 9,000 feet and then jump off
and float silently like you're a bird
among the clouds the birds actually do
come by sometimes it's like check out
what's this big bird flying up here you
can catch thermals and go way up above
the glaciers and it's one of the most
thrilling and delicious experiences that
I know that's incredible see you you
first experience that at what age and
probably it might you know late 20s and
did some and then sort of put it aside
and then I was traveling and teaching in
Europe and I saw a sign for paragliding
and I said oh gosh I really want to do
it and started and now each time I go
where there's high mountains and
paragliding that's one of my things that
I love doing you know there's something
about I've had most people have these
dreams once in a while if you're lucky a
dream of flying or maybe in your
meditation you have this sense of not
being limited to your body and and this
is the closest thing that I know because
it's absolutely silent and you're
floating there it's quite fantastic and
this is something you still do mm-hmm
and hope to do it and I hope to do it
next summer when I'm back in the Alps
and how old are you know 70 to 72 a good
man well we're gonna then go back a bit
in chronology and ask about childhood I
would love to hear you describe your
childhood what were you like as a child
what was your upbringing like well first
thing to say is I remember when I got to
Dartmouth College in 1963 and I called
my mom from the payphone in the dorm
sometime in that fall didn't call very
often but you know how it is
and I said mom I said guess what there
are a lot of other really fucked-up
families beside ours so that's
where we where we where we start so
there yeah
I'd three three brothers and my father
was a mixture of a tyrant and a really
abusive person and a brilliant guy I was
born on and on a Marine base in toward
the end of World War two and they didn't
send him overseas to do they put him in
the medical part of the Marines because
he tested so high on their tests that
they you know okay we're going to use
him for something so he was brilliant in
certain ways he was a biophysicist who
helped design some of the first
artificial hearts and lungs worked on
the space program but also did other
kinds of weird stuff like work for the
army biological weapons people not
making biological weapons but trying to
design things that were kind of computer
biological interfaces all kinds of
creative stuff but he was he was all he
had mental problems and so we didn't
know when the car pulled in whether we
were gonna get dr. Jekyll or mr. hyde he
would come in and you know either he
could shout the abusive thrill my mother
down the stairs rant chase after us try
to hit us whatever or we'd get this
interesting creative person what we
hardly ever had people come over when he
was around during the daytime is the way
we would because you never knew what you
would get and so um our family life in
my family life in some way was also
there were great parts of it because I
had my brothers and we were like our own
gang we moved all the time but we had
each other
and because he was wacky as well as
smart my father either quit or got fired
every year or two and then we would go
from one place to another I went to I
don't know eight schools by the time I
finished high school um so my childhood
partly was there were the happy things
of Raphael
being a boy with with three other boys
and adventures and then in the basement
my father had all kinds of scientific
equipment he had all this stuff from
World War two this huge radio from a
battleship that you could tune into a
thousand different you know shortwave
stations around the world um and
projects he was trying to design stuff
and so we learned from him you could
pretty much take or design or do
anything in the physical world and at
the same time I felt like my whole
childhood was also how to say it colored
with the fear of his violence and his
unpredictability so and I became kind of
a peacemaker in the family we all sort
of had our roles and now I do it as a
profession right trying to kind of make
it a little smoother between my parents
so they'd kill each other and each of my
brothers had their own strategy my twin
brother who was a lot bigger and much
more outgoing played football which I
certainly didn't I was skinnier and you
know I was in the orchestra and he was
the football player but anyway I
remember when he first got in a
fistfight with my dad because my father
was abusing our mom and my twin brother
had been as young men sometimes -
there's probably 13 14 and he grew
pretty big and he was looking in the
mirror you know making muscles in the
mirror to see how strong he'd become
anyway he just you know got into a
fistfight with my father and I was both
thrilled and terrified and but it worked
in some way because of the abuse settled
down quite a lot after that so that was
his this strategy was just to get angry
and then later kind of to go his own way
somewhat more all the worlds all have
been very close as brothers so there was
that at the same time there was a lot of
interest intellectual interest so we
read and learned about all kinds of
things both my parents were really
interested in the world around us and so
it was sort of this mixed thing of the
you know the gift of being together with
my brothers and a mom who was basically
pretty nurturing although she kept
trying to leave the him and never got it
together I think it was too scary and
the 50s to have four boys you know no
job and so we were in the middle of this
and the kind of healing that it took it
took a long time to do the inner healing
work from the pain of my family and I
remember when I became a Buddhist monk
and I was sitting these first years with
my teacher ajahn Chah in the forest
monasteries of Thailand on the border of
Thailand and Laos and I've been sitting
quietly and then some of these memories
or energy would come or I remember one
monk who had a hot near mind and the
forest did something that annoyed me and
I just got it raged inside and and I
said and I went to the teacher and I
said you know I'm really getting angry
here and he smiled he said yeah where do
you think that comes from or something
like that and I said well I don't know I
said I thought it was a peaceful guy who
was never gonna be like my father I
won't you know I'll be peaceful but it
turned out I just stuffed all that stuff
and so when I told it a teacher about he
said good should go back in your Hut
it's the hot season you get a little tin
roof and close the doors and windows and
put all your robes on and if you're
gonna be angry do it right sit in the
middle of that you know and sit in the
middle of the fire and don't be so
afraid of it because you're afraid of it
you're just kind of keep stuffing it and
on the other hand or if you're afraid of
it it'll just explode there's another
way to be with it
and so that was the beginning of some
healing just to realize that I could
actually tolerate the suffering and the
energy that was in my still carried from
trauma in my body and heart so we're
gonna absolutely come back to a jenshaw
because I have many questions on that
chapter in your life but just just so
that I can create the proper visual in
my own head so you sat there in your Hut
in the sweltering heat with all of your
robes on where were you angry in silence
were you yelling well what I was I was
pretty much angry in silence and that's
an interesting question
yeah I you know in the monastery the
culture was not was not much that you
would yell you could go somewhere about
the forest and yell but it was it wasn't
decorous or something people what the
hell's wrong with that monk so mostly I
was sitting in silence and then scenes
would come and I would realize well you
know I thought I was peaceful
I carry every in every cell of my body I
also carry both the pain and anger of my
childhood and my father and just that
the anger that comes with being a human
being a human incarnation and I was
never gonna have that but of course
there was and it lasted you know this
was I had days of and actually much
longer weeks or months of waves of this
coming and learning how to you know be
present for it and not get overwhelmed
by it so I want to backtrack and then
connect those dots so between childhood
and ending up in Thailand
you mentioned Dartmouth earlier and from
what I've read at least you were
initially pre-med and then ended up
Asian Studies could you describe that
experience in Dartmouth or how you went
from pre-med to Asian Studies well you
know we all get turned in these
mysterious ways in our life we think
we're going one direction and then
something happens unexpectedly and a
gateway opens so I was
coming from an organic chemistry class
to the class that I'd signed up for out
of interest on Asian Studies or Asian
philosophy or something and it was an
old professor I'm doctor wing Syd Chan
who had come up from Harvard he was kind
of emeritus there and he even sat
cross-legged sometimes you know on the
front of the room and would talk about
Lao Tzu and Taoism and they talked about
Buddhist teachings and how the Buddha
taught
suffering and its causes in its end and
that really all of a sudden I sat out
first and there's an end to suffering
there's a way to do and he said oh
there's all these teachings and
practices where you can transform your
heart and mind and I became thrilled
about it and realized that whatever
impulse I had to go to medical school
probably part of it came from wanting to
heal myself and so I started to take
more and more courses and then it was it
was the 60s and I became a card-carrying
hippy card-carrying LSD taking hippy as
a matter of fact and at the end of in
yeah when I was getting ready to
graduate there was still the draft and I
thought well I definitely don't want to
go over and kill people in a war that I
that I've been protesting at protesting
against so I decided to go into the
Peace Corps instead and asked them to
send me to a Buddhist country where
maybe I could find it one of those old
Zen masters that you read about and got
assigned to Thailand and when I got
there people you could kind of request
where you went they and and I said send
me in the most remote place you can I
wanted an adventure but I also wanted to
kind of reading all those old Zen
stories I wanted to see if that that
still existed so you know and there were
little detours like being in
haight-ashbury in the summer of love and
things like that that definitely
they changed my life also in a very deep
way because for at least for a time
there was a window when people were just
giving things away there was such a
sense that the world could be
transformed some of it as we know very
very naive but in the other hand it also
felt like a greater sense of brotherhood
and sisterhood than I had ever known
except with my own brothers who I loved
a lot and we've done a lot of things
together and I started to feel like
there are other ways for me and for the
world to be and live and that was that
was also very wonderful you mentioned
you mentioned a three-letter acronym
that we're probably not going to spend
too much time on but I you and I you and
I have had quite a number of
conversations where I've wanted to ask
you about some of your experiences with
psychedelics including LSD but we've
never really gotten into it so I figured
why not do it in front of a few million
people the the LSD at that point your
experiences with that did that inform
your decisions at all to then go into
the Peace Corps and end up in a busy
area it did and I've written a little
bit about it in in a couple of different
of my books chapters in books I've
written because then most of Buddhist
teachers and Hindu teachers of my
generation also started psychedelics you
know myself and almost all my colleagues
you know in the spiritual industry that
I'm in that was a beginning and for me
it showed an incredible possibility that
all is created out of consciousness and
the possibilities of inner freedom and
or basically I was able at the at the
best of it to see my body and my
personality and my history and realized
that that's not who I am to become much
more the conscious witness of it all to
see yes birth and
death and to go through those kind of
death rebirth experiences that can
happen at times in a deep session with
LSD or death of ego or sense of self or
removing and realizing wow there's a
freedom and a life force that's what
we're made of and that profoundly
influenced my interest in spirituality
and also interest in what the world can
be now just a few days ago I was on Maui
with my beloved wife Trudy and we were
visiting spending time with Ram Dass who
for listeners that don't know was the
author of this bestseller in the 60s
called be here now and it's now he's 86
and in a wheelchair but Ram Dass who had
been at Harvard University and was one
of the early explorers of LSD before he
went to India and became a spiritual
teacher in the living room while we were
there two days ago
Roland Fisher who is one of the senior
professors in psychopharmacologist at
Johns Hopkins University Medical School
Oh rollin rollin rollin rollin Griffiths
rather than Roland
excuse me Roland Griffiths and Roland
laid out all the research that's
happening now on the psilocybin that
he's been doing and its success for
people terminal cancer patients all
losing a great deal of their the fears
that they had working with people with
severe depression and it was a beautiful
session because you could hear how these
sacred substances and these
mind-altering substances when they're
used in the right context can really
transform human beings and NYU Johns
Hopkins there's a whole series of
studies that are happening now that are
finally bringing it back into the
mainstream
I'd love to underscore just a few things
that you mentioned
number one Ramdas for those people who
want to do additional reading formerly
known as Richard Alpert if I'm getting
that right yeah also has a fascinating
story coming full circle with
psychedelic research beginning I guess
at Harvard in some respects so it makes
sense to me why Rowland's research would
be mo so meaningful to him and a number
of other just just quick comments for
people number one is if you're
interested in in looking into these soul
címon which is considered the active
psychoactive ingredient in magic
mushrooms at Johns Hopkins and elsewhere
I've actually been involved with
crowdfunding and funding myself some of
the research related to treatment
resistant depression at Johns Hopkins
with roland griffiths as the senior
investigator and I'll be posting some
updates to that but fascinating work
looking at everything from and this is
also as you mentioned NYU and at other
very well-regarded universities alcohol
addiction nicotine / tobacco addiction
as you mentioned end-of-life anxiety in
cancer patients the implications are are
really profound and the data very very
promising and I wanted to also mention
to folks who are perhaps saying to
themselves well I'm not interested in
taking psychedelics myself that there
are people I know good friends of mine
who do not currently use psychedelics
but had the ego dissolving experience of
a non ordinary reality through
psychedelics that then led them to
become or contributed to them becoming
very very diligent meditators us and Sam
Harris who's a PhD in neuroscience and
thought of are very well known as in an
atheist or you know one of the Four
Horsemen of the Atheist apocalypse along
with Richard Dawkins and others is a
very close friend and extremely diligent
meditator
he's written about how his psychedelic
experiences which were in some respects
very some of them uncontrolled and you
really have a coin flip there it's in
terms of which direction you can go but
showed him possibilities within his own
mind that then led to a very very I'm
not gonna call it devout although I
should just about her practice so I
don't want to take us too far off the
rails but you go to Southeast Asia well
I want to say one more function where we
move on because we are talking about
this it turns out for those who are
listening that set and setting an
intention are extremely important if one
uses these you know psychedelics like
psilocybin or something to set the
intention to learn to open to have a
quiet it's not not as a party experience
absolutely makes you know brings your
attention inward and then all the kind
of discoveries become right in front of
your right in front of you but the other
thing is that whether it's right for
somebody to use psychedelics or to use
meditation these are all invitations to
step back and see the mystery of your
life because we tend to live in the you
know daily minutiae and checking off our
list of tasks that we have to do in
completing them work or you know or
eating or all the kind of things that
make up a day and we go onto automatic
and whether it's meditation and
difference or other spiritual
disciplines or for some people it also
can just be that they have what in Greek
is called a kata Bassam below you know
somebody close to them gets cancer or or
is dying or they have some accident or
something and all of a sudden you step
back near like whoa
life is uncertain the way I've been
taking it it's not just checking off the
list this is a mystery human incarnation
and what am I going to do with it and
wow look at this
how did I get in this body look at
plants and trees and and language the
air coming out of your mouth
you shape the different ways and it
vibrates a little drum in the ear of
someone else and I can say Golden Gate
Bridge and they can envision it and you
start to realize that all of it is alive
and made of consciousness and then the
whole sense of who you are and what
matters begins to shift and you start to
realize that life is not just getting
through the hoops but it actually also
can be a celebration of the heart of
something that you have to bring to the
world that you come out of life and my
friend melanoma so may who's a west
african shaman and medicine man also two
PhDs a kind of remarkable guy he says
with the dog rock people in West Africa
that he's from that they say that every
child comes into the world with a
certain cargo as their metaphor like the
cargo ships that ply the rivers of West
Africa and that that they're given gifts
to bring into the world and that we have
gifts to bring to this mystery which
include opening to it and as we do love
grows connection grows and and a whole
different way of being in the world
happens that we need so much at this
time so that's a little interlude there
before we move on to then that your next
question I welcome as many interludes as
you would like to interject and I wanted
to just ask you to say one more time
that it was I believe Greek word for
cotton baths which means a blow it's
like something comes and it just sets
your life spinning in an entirely
different direction right like a
catalyzing event and exactly I've had a
few of those recently that I'd like to
selfishly ask you about later but so I
can bookmark just so I can bookmark this
name Stanislav Grof
if I'm saying that usually that's
correct when just when did you meet him
roughly what age or what date just so I
can come back to it because this is
another thing at
meaning to ask you about for a long time
and get into but I haven't had the
chance so I had there's two things to
say when I came back from the monastery
and now it's you know I guess the year
that I connect with Stan was maybe 1973
I made two really important connections
I came back and start a psychology and
graduate school um it was in Boston and
first really important connection
happened when I went to a meeting of the
Massachusetts Psychological Association
and there was this guy who looked like
he he didn't look just like the straight
psychologists and it turned out he'd
just come back from India not long
before name Dan Goleman who was it who
was a graduate student at Harvard and he
projected on the screen this Tibetan
wheel of birth and death that you see in
the Tibetan Tonka's that that normally
would be taken as some kind of primitive
icon iconic you know symbol and he said
no no this is a psychological diagram
the Buddha was actually more than
anything else
he was a scientist of the mind and a
profound psychologist and here is how
craving turns into contentment and
here's how aggression can be transformed
into powerful energy to heal yourself
and others and he was going through this
diagram and I went and I talked to him
and he said oh you you come back from
monastery you've got to come over and so
he took me to David McClellan who had
been the chairman of the social science
and psychology department at Harvard at
that time the one who hired Tim Leary
and ROM das and then later had to fire
them for their LSD work and his house he
and his wife Mary were Quakers his home
was a kind of soiree where Ram Dass and
Tibetan Lamas like chögyam trungpa and I
think Krishnamurti and various spiritual
figures would come people were going to
Indian coming back and and I connected
with this whole group of folks who have
now been friends for forty five years
Richie Davidson was another that I met
there who's now one of the preeminent
neuroscientists in the world on studying
contemplatively science and effective
emotional neuroscience it was a whole
collective of people Dan Goleman who
wrote emotional intelligence that sold
ten million copies and many others and
then I got a job working for a nestled
in liked growth center in Boston at that
time because I was excited at all the
new gestalt bioenergetics what are the
things that are transformative here and
they asked me to help set up programs
and I thought well who do I want to who
do I want to meet so I set up a program
with John Lilly and I set up a program
with stan grof who was still at Johns
Hopkins and married at that time just
married to Joan Halifax Joan Groff and
we became friends and so we have Stan
and I have now worked together for forty
five years I went out to join him at
Esalen for many many years spending many
months together helping during his
development of the holotropic breathwork
that says this powerful breath
transformation and he has been a partner
in a heart trend for exploration and
we've traveled where we've taught in
Russia and in you know places in Europe
and various places around the world so
this is this is definitely a path that
we're gonna come down and dig further
into but I I'm gonna steer us to a John
job because I want to know how do you
land with the Peace Corps and ever more
remote well what most people would
consider a remote corner of the world
and end up finding a living master how
does that how does that actually happen
I don't know I but I assume you didn't
speak Thai at the time
I did actually just lost the Peace Corps
and then I had to learn Lao I did
because the Peace Corps at that time it
was a very early in the Peace Corps had
really good language training they
borrowed it from the Monterey Language
Institute so you know initially I didn't
speak that well but because I'd also
studied Chinese at Dartmouth listen it
came more easily and I was there working
in these in the health rural health
department on tropical medicine teams
mostly malaria but also typhoid and the
teams going out to different villages
and taking drawing blood and giving out
medicine and things like that and then
somebody said there's a there's a
Western monk in this province we heard
about do you want to me too I said of
course I do
so I I went to this little mount and and
walked up 2,000 steps to the old
Cambodian temple ruined at the top and
there was this very interesting guy
who had just finished a couple years
before the first Peace Corps I think in
Borneo and then got interested in
Buddhism and common ordained as a monk
and I talked with him he's now his name
da Jun su motto is his monks name
because he's still a monk and he became
quite famous in Thailand and then became
the abbot of a temple in in England and
I became friends with him and he said oh
I found I found a really fine teacher he
said you know a lot of them they kind of
take you you're a westerner and they
treat you special he said this guy
doesn't treat you any differently than
anyone else he just wants you to do that
work you know and learn the learned
learned the deepest way you can and he's
in this forest jungle and I said I'm
going there so having heard that I went
and I visited ajahn Chah and he was a
little bit like the Dalai Lama he was
funny and wise and very warm-hearted but
also very strict and very demanding but
he did it in this loving way and I
thought okay this is the real deal this
guy
looks like like what I was reading about
in all those end stories I've read that
he said to you and I'd love for you to
tell us when he said this to you I hope
you're not afraid to suffer if that's
true when did he say that in why did he
say then he so I visited him a number of
times and told him I was going to become
a monk and then I ordained in the
village where I was living in the Peace
Corps people wanted me to do that it was
a beautiful ritual and then after some
days made my way down to his temple and
he said that's that was his opening
gambit I'm walking in into the gate and
I see him I bow as I'm here and he looks
at me you know kind of leans back a
little little skeptical if he said all
right I hope you're not afraid to suffer
welcome and it was it was a it was like
you know you can come here just to kind
of do some interesting cool
anthropological experiment or something
like that if you're gonna do it we're
gonna put you through the training um
and and and he did but he you know there
was like this little smile as he said it
like okay you are you up for it all
right dude come on in well and what did
what did the training can consist of
what were what were some of the first
things that you had to do and then what
what was this suffering that he alluded
to what were some exams well maybe some
examples okay so of course the first
training was just how to walk around and
not have my robe you know fall on the
ground and embarrass me and every one of
those they come so they all loved it oh
yeah right look at the Westerner he said
he can't even chew gum and wear his
robes right or whatever so part of it
was just young familiarity of it at all
truly and otherwise right um there were
the there were the two kinds of
suffering the big suffering of course
was being alone with my own mind I mean
there you go you know having to do hours
of meditation when I didn't know what
the hell I was doing
and then as I talked about with anger or
fear or confusion or you know all those
kind of states learning to deal in a
very conscious and mindful way and then
more importantly in a compassionate way
in a kind and loving way with all the
energies that make up my humanity and
argue Manatee and that means when you
sit and you get quiet anything
unfinished in your heart will also come
up all the unfinished business so you
know relationships that I'd had that
ended badly in college or or certainly
stuff from my childhood and family
dreams that I carried things fulfilled
and not all that comes up it's um yeah
my friend Annie Lamott humorist and
writer says my mind is like a bad
neighborhood I try not to go there alone
and there's some way in which in
community sitting together with others
in meditation and then sitting in my
heart it was really facing myself and my
full humanity that was that that was
probably the most difficult thing
because then you get insanely bordure
insanely restless or and then how do you
deal with all those energies normally
when we're Restless or bored you know
what do we do we you know open the
refrigerator or you know go online or
something because we can't be with our
own loneliness or our own fear so it was
the inner and then there's outer ones
more than the outer one
yeah the outhouses ones were things like
hmm getting up the the bell would ring
at 3:30 in the morning and I'm not an
early riser by nature I got oh god here
we go and we walk through it was
actually very beautiful then we'd walk
through the forest at night either by
moonlight or sometimes you'd have a tiny
little flashlight er and in one of the
forest monasteries where there were a
lot of cobras we'd have a little stick
and you tap the path so that the snakes
would know you work feel you coming and
move out of the way you wouldn't step on
them and then we would sit
and silently for a couple of hours and
then do an hour of chanting on a hard
stone floor behind you so everybody else
seemed comfortable and my body was
killing me
and then at least once a week we would
sit up all night with the teacher and he
would sit there comfortably meditating
maybe talking with another colleague
that it would come and we'd just be
sitting and meditating and he would kind
of peek over us like how are you doing I
go god it's been four more hours
whenever you when is he gonna let us go
back to sleep and he didn't you know so
sitting up all night it got very cold in
the cold season and it got insanely hot
in the hot season and somehow learning
to live extremely simply with a set of
sandals and a set of robes and an alms
bowl and then you would eat what you got
offered in the village and we would
share it in that monastery with others
around us and sometimes you'd get nice
food and a lot of times in the dry
season you get really really skimpy food
and there wasn't that much to eat and so
picture a day where you get up at 3:30
in the morning you know you sit for a
couple of hours in meditation and do
long than an hour long chanting on a
stone floor then it's getting dawn and
you walk barefoot you know three miles
five miles ten miles with a almsbowl and
a handful of other monks and get your
food and come back whenever you've been
offered and that's the food for the day
and then you go back to your meditation
or to the work of the monastery of
sewing robes or drawing water from the
well and it's you know muggy and 105
degrees hot season and then you go back
and you join in the community for more
meditation and then the teacher smiles
and say how are you doing you know and
then other kinds of practices for
example we had a charnel ground there
and so what grad a charnel
ground which is where a cremation ground
where people bodies would be burned and
so on occasion would go to a cremation
and then sit up all night and
contemplate death and you know look at
the body and then watch as it burned and
then do these meditations where you
would reflect on well this is going to
happen to the body that you're
inhabiting as well who do you think you
are do you think you're this physical
body made of you know hamburgers or
lettuce or whatever you happen to eat is
that your are you hamburgers and lettuce
you know or or are you your feelings or
you your thoughts who are you really
born into this body like Cowen's yeah so
anyways
and the ALMS ball so you would be did
you eat whatever you gathered in one
meal was it spread throughout the well
one meal you eat one meal a day which
makes you very easy to makes your life
easy and at the same that monastery
things were shared there was other
monasteries I stayed in where you would
just eat what was put in your own bowl
and you didn't have to eat everything
that was given to you there were some
things that were you know in the dry
poor season there would be curries that
were too hot for me to eat because they
used the chillies to kind of preserve
the preserve preserve the food but you
know when when it was a really poor
village or something you know they would
have to make curries out of field mice
or filled with bat or bats or you know I
remember eating there was a curry that
was made out of basically the
grasshoppers that had come spread
through and there was this whole big you
know insect wave of insects that were
kind of eating the crops and they've
been collected them all and made a
career out of it so you know okay this
is this is what you get for your food
today new I think I might take
Supper's over the over the bats but yeah
when it's really highly spiced you can't
tell what it's mystery that's we all had
mystery meeting middle school anyway
this was like mystery meat on steroids
exotic mystery mean what was the what
was the longest period of time that you
spent in silence during that time in
Thailand well then I went to a Burmese
monastery because I wanted to do this
very intense meditative training and I
spent about 500 days so unless less than
a year and a half in silence the with
the exception that I would talk to the
teacher mm-hmm
every couple days I'd have a little
10-minute conversation about what was
happening my meditation and the rest
I was just sitting and walking 18 hours
a day when I could or or so sleeping a
little bit and I remember at one point
it was relatively early on I'd been
sitting and walking and and pushing it
as young men do you know I'm gonna get
enlightened all of that not moving
sitting with a lot of pain which is also
part of what happened at at the forest
monastery seeing on a stone floor for
hours and without moving really had to
learn how to deal with your own physical
pain and I was exhausted from sitting
and walking in my little hot that I had
for that long retreat and after a couple
months I thought I'm really tired I did
I got a lie down but then I thought well
but I'm not gonna nap for very long
because I'm I'm on my way to
enlightenment whatever I'm gonna do this
right so I said all right I'll lie down
on the wooden floor rather than on the
little mat that I had and that way I
won't sleep sit long and I'm lying there
and then I wake up and I get up and I
walk very slowly doing this mindful slow
walking to the end of the hut and look
out the window toward where some of the
other monks and the teachers lived some
some way down some way down through the
trees
[Music]
and then I turn around and I start
walking the other direction in this this
meditation hut that I had then you could
walk probably it was maybe 15 18 feet
long it was long and narrow and I see
this body lying on the floor and all of
a sudden I go oh that's me and then I
realized that I'm having out of the body
experience and what had happened is that
I was so intent I'm not gonna sleep long
I'll get up very soon and that intention
was really strong but my body didn't
want to get up so I got up but it was it
wasn't in my body and I walk very slowly
and I appeared down at my body and I
turned around and walked the other or
walked back and then the second time I
walked Becca I got closer and that I
fell into my body and I woke up I said
oh wow that's interesting but what I saw
out the window wasn't just like a dream
because I was watching you know my
teacher and talking to these other monks
and that I got up again and that's
exactly what was happening and that was
the first of a series of all kinds of
very interesting experiences that happen
and those the what would other examples
of those types of unusual experiences be
and did was it your time in Burma that
found you experiencing these for the
first time well first of all the first
experiences even though I had
experimented with meditation back in in
Union College and so forth
were experiences again that came through
psychedelics and so I was familiar with
all kinds of weird and and powerful and
and mysterious or mystical kind of
experiences but they but there's
something about learning how to navigate
it without taking a substance and
learning that your own consciousness is
the field that you can that you can
learn to navigate first all the
personality and emotions and history and
so forth
but then you start to realize that
you're bigger than that that who you are
is
just your thoughts and feelings in your
mind and so whether it's out-of-body
experience or the experience of vastness
of becoming the sky
within which everything arises and
passes or the experience of profound
silence or of the void where you enter
enter a stillness before experience even
arises or the experience of luminosity
where where my body would dissolve into
light their time sitting as you get
concentrated in Samadhi or concentration
builds that your whole body and mind
open up and you know first you get the
elements your body can feel heavy like a
stone the earth element or can fuel so
light that you have to peak your open
your eyes and make sure you're not
floating because it feels like you're
floating in the air or it can be filled
with fire and you feel like you're in
the middle of the raging fire or it can
get icy cold you know or all kinds of
vibrations and Kundalini energies and
chakras start to open and sometimes it's
present sometimes it's not you know as
deep energies start to move through your
body they also kind of push open the
places that are held close so that when
your heart starts to open in deep
meditation sometimes it feels like
you're having a heart attack that's
physically painful because all the all
the things that you've held around your
heart to protect yourself start to
loosen or when the energy hits your
throat and it starts to open weird
sounds come out you know and then you
get to visions that come in that yeah
you know brow chakra you start to see
all kinds of colors and visions and hear
things all possibilities of the play of
consciousness can start to open after
both period of silence but also really
deeply training attention and
concentration so these experiences just
to put them in or at least part of what
you said in context for people listening
I there there are a number of things you
mentioned but one in particular that
in the chest that I experienced in the
10-day retreat done it spirit rock which
which for which you are one of the the
instructors of the lead instructor and I
it was an incredibly powerful experience
and listening to your description of
some of the feelings it makes me want to
go to the jungle and spend time doing
this type of training however the
ten-day retreat as you know from
firsthand observation and interacting
with me was incredibly difficult for me
and terrifying it a number of points
where I felt like I had crossed a
boundary into maybe even madness where I
was fearful I wouldn't be able to return
from and so I'm curious to know during
that period of time in Thailand and
Burma could be afterwards as well but
when you were in the in the jungle and
doing this very intense work were there
any particular points when you wanted to
quit to go to go home absolutely I mean
I remember I I got what I think was
malaria I'm a really high fever and I
was sick as a dog and I'm lying in the
bottom of my little Hut there and high
fever and shivering and ajahn Chah came
to visit me and in the Lao language and
he was he was also funny in quite blunt
and the Lao language is a very
straightforward kind of that sentence
structures are fairly simple so he
looked at me and he said sick huh and I
said yeah and he said hurts all over huh
I said it hurt us he said hot and cold
yeah he said you know makes you afraid I
not he said makes you want to go home
and see your mother doesn't it and I'm
not think there and then he looked at me
and he said you know this is the jungle
fever this is malaria we've all had it
but now there's some good medicine I'll
send the medicine monk over and in a
couple days you'll be fine and then he
looked at me and he said you can do this
you know you can do this so I mean that
was an example of why me go home what
am i doing what kept what kept you going
I mean I don't to interrupt it's like
what kept you going I'm imagining 500
days of silence I could barely handle 10
days you know Tim I mean what's kept you
going what keeps any of us going about
things that we care about I had somehow
I don't know kind of wacky but I think
also important kind of passion to say I
want to understand or I you know I've
started down this road and I want to see
where it goes and I think all of us find
at a certain point in our life that
there or if we're lucky that something
really matters and you've done it in
your work and your travel you want to
explore what your human capacity is and
I read read these old Zen stories and as
I said I want to see if this is true I
want to find out and then as I started
things started to happen like that out
of the body experience and rapture and
changes in and openings and I realized
there's really something to learn here
but there are a couple of the things
that that I want to add to this one of
them that's the most important is that
it turns out that it wasn't and it isn't
so much about the actual experiences so
ajahn Chah my teacher talked about how
in his own training for the first eight
years in the jungle he had been a very
ardent meditator and had all kinds of
insights and dissolving and samadhi and
john experiences all kinds of somebody
is a weak in some bodies yeah or sauna
how would you try found some bodies it
has a lot of meanings as a word but it
it can mean profound states of
concentration in which the mind is awls
into light or into joy or bliss or
becomes absorbed with anyone of all
kinds of states so he went to the most
famous teacher of that time another odd
John Donne gentleman and told about all
these experiences in the the master
looked back into and said ha you missed
the point these are just experiences you
know it's like gone to the movies and
you have a roommate
to comedy and you war movie of a
documentary you know and you have you
know a Disney movie he said they're just
movies on the screen some pleasant some
unpleasant the only question is to whom
do they happen turn your attention back
and ask look to see who is the witness
of these what is the consciousness that
is knowing these ever-changing
experiences this is where your
liberation will come
he said become his language if I
translated is the one who knows become
the knowing rather than the experiences
and then you can tolerate anything and
you can respond with love and
understanding because you rest in the
timeless consciousness which is your
true nature so part of what I also
learned in meditation and teach is that
it's not so much about the experiences
oh I want to have this or that
experience but it's this profound
turning back to ask Who am I what is
this consciousness itself and that was
born into this body that will leave it
we can talk about death at some point if
you want what is this mysterious
consciousness itself so there is that
and then that I also had the opportunity
of being with a few other teachers and
one of my the one of the people that I
was very close to and inspired me
profoundly was a Cambodian monk named
Maha goes Ananda who was the Gandhi of
Cambodia and when I met him we were
living and training together in a forest
monastery in Thailand and it was during
the time the Khmer Rouge came to power
and and eventually killed two million
Cambodians in a kind of genocide and he
was he survived because he wasn't in
country but all 19 of his family members
were killed his temple burned you know
all the all the Buddhas
texts and so forth were destroyed and
when he was able to he went to the
refugee camps refugees were pouring out
of Cambodia by the hundreds of thousands
and he went to the refugee camps on the
border of Thailand and Cambodia I was
able to go with him and at a certain
point and he decided to open a temple in
the middle of one of the biggest refugee
camps here's fifty or a hundred thousand
people these tiny little bamboo huts and
got the mission from the UN HCR High
Commissioner of refugees and built a
platform with a little roof over it and
put an altar with the traditional
Cambodian Buddha on it and so forth but
it was a camp with the Khmer Rouge
underground lots of them and so they put
the word out that if anyone went to be
with this monk when they got out of the
camp back to Cambodia they would all be
shot so we wondered who would if anyone
would come and went through the camp the
day the opening day with a big kind of
temple Gong ringing it and twenty-five
thousand people poured into the central
square around this little temple my god
and he Lagos Ananda sat there and he was
a scholar he spoke 15 languages and he
was a you know extremely kind-hearted
human being who had suffered enormous
Lee and had transformed it into the kind
of compassion that we think of with the
Dalai Lama or something like that in
fact they became friends and goes Ananda
became the head of all in Cambodian
boozin but there he was at this point
sitting looking out at 25,000 people who
had suffered immense traumas and you
could see there was a grandmother and
the only two surviving grandchildren
that she had or an uncle in one nice and
their faces were the faces of trauma and
of survivors
and I thought all right what is he gonna
say to them and he sat very quietly for
a long time just in their presence and
then he put his hands together in this
kind of modest way and began to chant in
the microphone yet it sound system in
Cambodian and in Sanskrit or Pali the
Buddhist language one of the first
verses from the Buddhist texts that goes
hatred never ceases by hatred but by
love alone is healed this is the ancient
and eternal law and he chanted it over
and over in Cambodian and in Sanskrit
Pali and pretty soon the chant was
picked up and in a little while 25,000
people were chanting this verse with him
and I looked out and they were weeping
many of them because they hadn't heard
their sacred chants for years but also
because he was offering them a truth
that was even bigger than their sorrows
that hatred never ends by hatred but by
love alone is healed this is the ancient
and eternal law and they were sitting in
the middle of the the the healing energy
of the Dharma of the teachings of the
heart that can liberate us later on goes
Ananda who was nominated for the Nobel
Peace Prize a number of times spent 15
years walking through the killing fields
and the you know mined areas and so
forth leading people on foot back to
their village and he said to the
refugees you can't go back in a bus or
the back of a truck or something like
that you have to reclaim your land with
love and so he would lead a thousand
people and he'd be in the front with a
bell and a gong and a few other monks
and the whole way back they would be
chanting the chance of loving-kindness
so that by the time they got to
their village whatever had been
destroyed there was the sense that they
were reclaiming not just the land but
they were reclaiming their own hearts
that's a beautiful really beautiful
story and it it prompts me to ask a
question that I struggle with answering
myself and it's also a question many of
my friends have asked themselves and
I'll take a stab at it how do you decide
when to do deep inner work and take an
extended period to do that versus being
in the world and trying to impact others
in the world and to just provide a
little bit of background on that I have
friends who are building businesses or
building careers of some type or
families and I at this point do not have
wife kids or company to build at least
with a large organization and I've come
back from various experiments so
journeys experiences over weeks or
months and shared these with them and
they've they've expressed this longing
this deep yearning to do something
similar and then they ask this question
like how do i how do i best decide if
and when to do the deep extended work
versus being in the world and i know it
might be a false dichotomy you might not
have to choose but I'll talk a little
bit more just just to fill the space but
the I had this experience personally not
long ago when I was in South America and
had someone telling me in second Spanish
which was not their native language this
is an indigenous tribe but this Apple
this mayor effectively who worked a lot
with different plant medicines and he
said that he recommended one 15-month
diet very very strict 15 month period
with many different restrictions no sex
no alcohol no pork etc and to develop
certain
capacities and to practice in effect I
mean at certain types of meditative
practices so I struggle with this myself
as well how do you how do you suggest
someone think through so did you give up
sex and pork I've done it for short
periods at a time
I'm not a year and a half I've done it
for weeks at a time but not for 15
months but what appealed to me about
that
definitely not the lack of sex in pork I
like both of those things it was he said
that's something you only have to do
once in your life and it opens doors and
creates opportunities that are difficult
if not impossible to achieve otherwise
so of course that's very tantalizing but
15 months is a really really long time
to opt out of everything else and I'm
not saying it has to be 15 months for
some people as you know setting aside
even 10 days to do a silent retreat is
hard and I know there are things that
they can do on an ongoing basis like
morning meditation and so on but for
those who are really drawn to this
extended deeper work how do you think
about and that that's why I go sananda
brought it up for me she'd spent so much
time outside of his country and then
went back and was really on the on the
ground doing work with locals how do you
think about that or suggest someone
think about it first my answer is yes
you know because all of the things that
you say are true that yes there you know
most cultures encourage at some point
human beings most wise cultures you can
beings to step out of their ordinary
roles and their ordinary routine whether
you go to the mountains or the ocean you
know or a temple or a change
how you're living so that you can open
up to the mystery and so that you also
can open up to love because what I saw
with my teachers and ghosts Ananda was
wild logic cha another is that they were
able to love no matter what it was
really because they they inhabited
consciousness in a very different way
than just a small sense of self there
was something much a possibility that we
could live with forgiveness and love and
be really effective in the world at the
same time so they're not separate and
that's sort of what your question is how
do we live in the world and at the same
time you know what trainings and how do
we connect with something deeper and
part of it is just intuitive you you
know Tim you knew more you know or young
children and so forth it's not the time
to go on a long retreat your kids are
your practice and in fact you can't get
a Zen master who's going to be more
demanding than you know an infant with
colic right were you or you know or a
teenage you know certainty it's just
where you but with the young ones you
know your Zen master might say you've
got to get up early in the morning and
you know once in a while you might roll
over the kid is crying and sick you have
to get up your family needs tending and
that you know if you're even vaguely a
responsible and caring parent as you
that becomes your practice and if you
think well if only I could be in the
great Zen temple of Kyoto or an ashram
in India or down in the Amazon with Tim
you know taking ayahuasca or whatever
the slant medicine they give you know
your kid this can be like ayahuasca on
steroids okay you wanna you want to face
yourself and your own limitations and
your own you know you want to look at
the the small sense of self and find out
how to live with it with a freer and
bigger spirit here we've just hired
someone to live with you and train you
full-time so it's really you know and
that's an important thing but but what
makes it work is that you have that
intention not just to soldier through it
but to say let this be a place where I
awaken graciousness and inner sense of
freedom and peace as things come and go
where I awaken the possibility of
presence in pleasure and pain and joy
it's our own gain and loss and all the
changes that I find a an inviolable or a
timeless place of becoming the loving
witness of it all becoming the loving
awareness that says yeah now I'm having
a family experience and this is the
place to find freedom because freedom is
not in the Himalayas or in the Amazon
the only place it's found is in your own
heart exactly where you are and that's
what goes on on to Todd and wonder
Odadjian cha that's really what they
wanted to communicate now that being
said if you have an opportunity and
you're drawn to it like somebody you
might do you know Jack Dorsey yeah I do
know Jack Young so Jack just did his
first ten day meditation real good for
him and he tweeted about I wouldn't say
it otherwise but he tweeted about it and
it was you know one of the top
transformative experiences of his life
and it's not to say 10-day retreats or
the be-all and end-all they are they're
very powerful and compelling but you
even if you have a company or even if
you have a family there might be a
period of a week or some days where you
can in fact get away and step out of
those roles and turn inward and that can
be tremendously valuable so I think both
are important you just have to listen
what that when the time is right so
there are so many things that this this
brings up the first though is just a
housekeeping for people who may not
recognize the name Jack Dorsey that's
Jack at Jack I believe it is on Twitter
of you might add then wonder how did he
get that user handle well I use is one
of the people behind Twitter so he is of
Twitter and square Fame among many
others fascinating fascinating guy so
people can check him out the the comment
on the infant being the full-time
trainer working with you 24/7 reminded
me also since you mentioned Ram Dass are
clear
of a quote of his that I like and I'm
gonna paraphrase I'm sure but if you
think you're enlightened go spend a week
with your family which i think is a
fantastic one and that's part of the
reason and in you know some of the
backstory but we all have I would
imagine we all have tough things that
happen to us experienced traumatic
experiences as children have a lot of
triggers related to family members
typically and for me the force to break
takes a number of different forms but
that includes a trip every six months an
extended trip of two to four weeks with
my parents and my brother when he can
make it so that's only after being
introduced to meditation something that
I would even consider as a practice and
the the last point I'll mention just out
of my personal experience is that a
there's a piece of paper I have in my
wallet and I've had in my wallet for a
few years now it's getting a bit worn
down it's a piece of construction paper
and an ex-girlfriend gave it to me who
who knew me very well and it says the
task that hinders your task is your task
that's a good reminder for me I wanted
to ask you two questions that are
personally important but but also may
apply to other people the first is the
question that I believe you mentioned
ajahn Chah perhaps others have indicated
is the question versus the the
experiences or movies of these say
out-of-body experiences and so on to
whom do they happen right to whom do
they happen is this a KO on like what is
the sound of one hand clapping where
there isn't really an answer your are
you're expected to arrive at is it is
the value in contemplating the question
more than any answer yes both no yes but
no yeah because it is it's a profound
contemplation for us one of the great
you know questions of
human incarnation who are we how do we
get into that how did you get into this
body with the Wiggly things on the end
of your limbs you know and those little
bits of a clause that you have you know
it's nails in a vestigial tail and a
hole at one end into which you stuff
dead plants and animals and glug them
down through the tube I mean the whole
incarnation thing is really pretty wild
so who are we and then what are what how
do we make meaning about what this is
that this is a lifetime question and
that way that it's a Coe on but in
another way it also actually does have
any answer and the answer of course has
to be found by each person the answer to
point toward it it's very clear that
you're not just you're you know salad
and vegetables and hamburger body and
you're not just your emotions I hope
because they're always changing and your
thoughts good god I hope you're not your
thoughts so you start to realize all
right what is there then what is this
self who am I in neuroscience you know
there was a Time magazine issue on
modern neuroscience where it said
neuroscientists have searched throughout
the brain over many decades now and come
to the conclusion that they cannot find
the self located anywhere in the neural
mechanisms of the brain and that it
simply does not exist but what does
exist is the sense of self that's built
out of a sense of identification with
our thoughts and body and so forth it's
all wise inappropriate we should be but
we also know that it's not the end of
the story and you know it from walking
in the high mountains or listening to an
extraordinary piece of music or making
love or taking some some sacred medicine
you know we're sitting at the bedside of
someone when they die that mysterious
moment when spirit leaves the body or
when a child is born we have these
moments where we open to mystery and
realize that who we are is not just our
personal history or our body and
emotions that we become
the consciousness itself the witnessing
awareness that we are the loving
awareness that was born into this body
and that becomes actually a direct
knowing a direct experience so there is
a way in which we also can come home to
ourselves and it brings a tremendous
sense of freedom and well-being as all
the movies of ever-changing life happen
to us so that's why I said yes yes and
no and both and a little aside thinking
about you going back to your family as a
practice and twice a year as your doing
I just want to remind you and the
listeners that Buddha and Jesus both had
a hard time when they went back to their
families so don't think that you know
there's something wrong with you
this part it's that's why they call it
nuclear family I think the there's
another I guess it's a word more than a
question that I'd love to ask you to
define and that is compassion or
compassionate when you use that word or
those words what what do you mean
exactly or what would you like it to
mean for people I would like to
distinguish compassion from empathy and
I'll use a simple illustration if you're
on the playground and you see a kid
being bullied and you feel oh that must
feel terrible that hurts right that's an
empathy and empathy can be useful it
also can be you can get overwhelmed by
empathy if you don't know what to do
with it but there's some way in which
you start to feel resonating you because
we are not limited to these bodies we
are actually an interconnected system of
consciousness and I'll talk about that a
little bit more in a minute but we all
know whether it's mirror neurons from
neuroscience or the field of presence as
Neuros
you know scientists like dan Siegel talk
about extended presents that we can feel
empathy with one other when someone says
someone's angry someone's hurting
compassion is the next step you you see
or recognize you feel and then you care
you care about it and you want to if you
can do something that helps so that you
see the kid being bullied and you
realize I want to tell the teacher or
the you know principal or I want to just
walk over there and say something or
intervene to help stop it and so
compassion it's called the quivering of
the heart when it wants to move to
alleviate the suffering of yourself
because you can have self compassion
it's very important or those around you
and it's born into and the earliest
studies of the infant's you know at Yale
and various places like that show that
even very very very small children have
this resonance and this kind of care and
so it's not shut down in us we we're a
species that's interconnected and we
care for one another and this is your
birthright this natural natural
compassion and through practice and
meditation you can reawaken it you can
extend it and it can become your way of
living and moving in the world as a
little aside and I'll just bookmark this
one just got back from a conference with
our dear friend Adam Ghazali our mutual
friend Richie Davidson who's another of
the most famous neuroscientists
especially in this area and a number of
other some contemplatives and
neuroscientists and some technologists
from the valley and VC talking about how
to build compassion into our interface
with the technological world compassion
tack and then from starting from the
very simplest things of projects like
can you build a Fitbit for compassion
where instead of your body where you can
either know moments
CAIR around you or in yourself or be
prompted to care for yourself you know
or when you say to Siri or Alexa you
know I'm feeling lonely or you know and
so forth what kind of response do you
get from them from the algorithms and
all of that because the the UK England
just appointed their first minister of
loneliness for the country and I hope
you think it was a joke but it's not
it's like an old Beatles song all the
lonely people there are 10 million
lonely people in England they've
estimated and this Minister has got cut
and it's you know it's for isolation and
loss of capacity and health and all
kinds of reasons that loneliness makes
things way worse but there's some way in
which compassion is that which connects
us and it's a beautiful thing even if
you walk down the street and you see
someone you know who's struggling and so
forth doesn't mean you have to fix the
whole world that's not your job that
would be egotistical but you can reach
your hand out and mend the things that
you can you can tend the things that you
can and you can do it not because oh you
pity them those poor people but because
they're your family
you recognize that we're common humanity
we're in this together I'd like to build
on that and preface it with a comment on
the text so you mentioned collaborating
with Adam and well he's discussing the
potential of combining or utilizing
technology to help people to develop an
and harness compassion and some folks
listening might be like ow come on
that's so pie-in-the-sky but I'd like to
point out that you've already
collaborated successfully with Adam on
software like meta Train yeah Emmie di
tra i-n which was one of the tools Adam
has used in his end of one or end of two
experiments in rejuvenating his mental
capacity to I want to say in his 20s and
Adams Adams one of those guys you can't
tell if he's 28 or 45 he's just a silver
fox who always looks too young so I
don't
but he's not he's not 22
but the Metatrader is one of the tools
that he utilized and I don't remember
the the name that he used for this run
of experiments you might know that the
training that he did neuro Man or
something like that was very very
successful so that you already have a
track record of collaborating
successfully with neuroscientists and
technologists the on the the compassion
front I'd love to use that as a segue to
loving-kindness and by way of personal
example I failed I failed as a strong
word I quit I stopped meditating after
many many attempts had a very absurdly
high number of false starts over many
years and it's it really stuck after a
number of experiments and experiences I
had doing three or four day trainings
with say travel meditation and having
the social accountability being
accountable to someone else is very
helpful but another turning point was
experimenting with loving-kindness
meditation and I think in part it
succeeded because it took the focus off
of me me me III and allowed me to focus
on others but I'd like to read a brief
paragraph from a profile of you in the
New York Times's from 2014 and feel free
to correct anything that is incorrect
but I'll give it a read first and I
quote in the West cornfield says quote
we encounter a lot of intense striving
ambition and a lot of self-criticism
self judgment and self-hatred and quote
concerned he initially turned to the
Dalai Lama for advice but self-hatred
was such a foreign concept to the
Tibetan Buddhist that he wasn't able to
offer any real insight over time
cornfield and his colleagues began to
believe that America's needed particular
meditation closely I'm sorry practice
closely linked to the concepts of self
forgiveness and loving-kindness a
training in the unconditional acceptance
of imperfection without such a
foundation says cornfield meditation can
easily become and this is the part that
I underlined and start without this
foundation says cornfield meditation can
easily become yet another form of
driving quote another thing you do to
make yourself better end quote instead
of a path to true contentment so could
you please describe for folks what
loving-kindness meditation practice
looks like and elaborate in any way that
you feel might be might be useful or
helpful for folks yeah and that meeting
which was some decades ago was the Dalai
Lama yeah he didn't understand when we
talked about self-hatred he couldn't you
there's no word for that very back and
forth with his translator what does this
mean finally looked up he said but this
is a mistake why would anyone do this
but many asked how many of you there was
a group of us aware teachers have
experienced this and almost everyone
raised their hand so we see that when
people begin in our culture and in the
West to meditate or to turn in turn
inward really that it's very common to
encounter a lot of self-criticism self
judgment or even self-hatred and you
know they're all the causes from art
these are all kind of conditioning that
we got from from our childhood our
education and so forth but what it means
is that you're sitting there saying I'm
not doing it right I'm no good you turn
the meditation into one other one other
thing that you don't do right because
you can't control your mind the truth is
that you can't control your mind easily
that's not the point there's a different
way of approaching your mind which gives
you tremendous capacities but it's not
oh I have to stop my thinking or I don't
want to have these feelings and I hate
having all these judgments I don't want
to be so judgmental Islands toppled I
hate this
judging mind what is it just more
judgment so instead as you become first
able to become the loving witness the
the mindful loving awareness that says
oh this is the judging mind and it's
been trying to protect me thank you for
trying to protect me I don't need you
now thank you all of a sudden there's a
distance from the from the painful or
destructive or
or self-critical thoughts
simply by witnessing and with loving
awareness and acknowledging them this
becomes the Gateway to the practice of
loving kindness and self self compassion
and very often people can't do it for
themselves they feel that's too much of
a stretch like why would I wish myself
well it feels egotistical and so the way
that this practice begins for in
skillfully for such folks is instead to
think of someone that you really care
about a lot and to picture them remember
them put them in your mind's eye and
feel the kind of well wishing you would
want for them you know may they be
protected and safe from difficulty may
they be held in loving kindness may they
be well healthy strong and you wish them
that may they be happy and you do this
for a time a kind of inner well wishing
and also maybe you feel as you think of
this person that you care about if you
let yourself also tune in to the measure
of Sorrows they have the struggles that
every human being has you know and it
tenderizes your heart as you think of
them because you don't want them to
suffer you feel the kind of rising of
compassion and care so may they hold
themselves and compassion may they be
safe and protected and well and you do
that with one or two people that you
care about for time and then you can
imagine even as I'm describing this and
you follow in your own heart you can
imagine these two loved ones
looking back at you with the same
kindness and saying just as you wish us
protection and safety and happiness and
well-being and you know in compassion
they gaze at you and they say you too
may you be safe
and protected and may you be filled with
tender compassion for yourself and
kindness may you to be healthy and well
and may you be happy they want you to be
happy
I think about when I'm doing this I'm
visualizing some loved ones and I know
that as I do it I can feel they want
that for me and then finally as you feel
that from these loved ones you can put
your hand on your body or your heart
even if you like and take it in and and
then begin to realize that you can wish
this for yourself may I hold all of the
joys and sorrows of my life with
tenderness and kindness may I hold my
struggles with compassion may be filled
with loving kindness and loving
awareness may I be safe and protected
may I be well strong or healed and as
you repeat these simple intentions that
have been done for thousands of years
it's as if your cells are listening and
this is the research of people like Liz
Blackburn and Elissa EPEL who who
Blackburn got the Nobel Prize for
discovering the telomerase and the
telomeres at the end of the caps and DNA
it turns out that your sounds listen to
your heart and the to your intention
that consciousness affects your body and
little by little even though it can
bring up its opposite I hate myself
I've never be good enough and you see
all those and you say thank you for
trying to protect me
I appreciate that may I be well may I be
safe may I be held in love and little by
little like water on a stone it starts
to soften the places that are holding
your lack of self forgiveness your lack
of care and loving kind of starts to
grow in you and it's a very beautiful
practice there's lots of places you can
find it on my in my work and teachers
like Sharon Salzberg and I my children
and Tara brach and and and so forth
are there any particular do you have any
guided loving-kindness meditations or
audio that you can recommend people
listen to I do and I don't know they
could go on my website jack Kornfield
comm I think they will be on there I do
know for sure didn't have a whole series
of great programs with sounds true
sounds true comm that include
meditations on the mind vast as the sky
meditations on compassion and
loving-kindness
and I did a book one of the books I've
done is called a lamp in the darkness
and it contains I think eight or nine
different I'm guided practices that you
can get either with it on the CD but you
can get it as a download basically and
sounds true also has that and has a
compassion practice and a grounding
practice in a kind of vast sky like mine
practice and so forth so you so you can
look a look for all of those beautiful
it's a beautiful thing is that you can
learn this and I was a couple of years
ago invited to be part of the first
white house Buddhist leadership
gathering there were a hundred and
twenty Buddhist leaders from around the
country from different communities I
don't think that's going to happen again
very soon but there it was and one could
hope and we talked most of the
communities did beautiful things that
were involved in the soup kitchens and
tending the homeless and projects you
know to support healing for whether it
was malaria are there other diseases in
different other parts of the world and
so forth all kinds of great stuff and
certainly meditation and when I got to
talk which was kind of a summary talk
toward toward the end of it I mentioned
that in the in this historical record
whether it's true or not that the the
text and so forth describe the Buddha
meeting with kings and princes and men
stirs and so forth and probably if the
Buddha were were around now he would go
to the White House if he were invited he
certainly would have met with Obama and
who knows now and he had advice about
why society which he would give to
leaders and he'd say if you can train
your people to meet one another with
respect to listen with respect to
differences and to come together
peacefully listening to one another and
then then your process ID will prosper
not decline and if your society tends
the vulnerable among them the the young
people the old people those who are sick
it will prosper not decline and if your
society tends the environment around it
in a healthy way it will prosper it not
decline and so these are these are
principles of compassion and why society
that you could read perhaps in a number
of great traditions from the Iroquois
nation or from the taoist sages but
here's the beautiful piece yes these are
these are good things meeting in harmony
and discussing and harmony and being
respectful for one another and so forth
there are practices that you can teach
and learn that develop this capacity so
that in our elementary schools now you
know through organizations like castle
which is a consortium for
social-emotional learning that's worked
in you know 10,000 schools kids learn
social and emotional learning they learn
compassion and it changes their lives
they're better academically and all
these kids carry that you know the
troubles of our times they hear the news
they see the trauma even in their own
family to teach you how to steward your
own heart from when you're young and
then these capacities are now be
incorporated as we know mindfulness
based stress reduction in clinics and
hospitals and businesses in you know
there's the mindfulness teachers that
for the when the Seattle Seahawks won
the championship or the the Chicago
in the LA Lakers when there were
championship teams they had a they had a
meditation coach a mindfulness coach
George Mumford a good friend and that
these capacities can be learned wherever
we are and they transform our life it's
not just by accident or that you have
this beautiful experience on the
mountains or making love but you can
make that alive for you through these
trainings every day every part of your
life Jack there was a question I was
planning on asking at some point anyway
and I think this is a good segue which
is how can you get a busy person hooked
on my fulness practice you know it would
be a first step or how to start and
since we're talking about
loving-kindness I would like to give a
bit of a hard sell for loving-kindness
meditation is one option because I
recall perhaps it was two years ago I
was really beating myself up and for
people who don't know this about me I've
spent the majority of my life being the
my own worst enemy in terms of inner
dialogue extremely brutal and hyper
critical and loathsome of myself in in
so many different respects I was going
through a particularly intense and
difficult time with that inner critic
just ruthlessly beating myself up and at
that point another friend of mine
chade-meng tan who created the search
inside yourself classic Google he was a
very early um engineer which became the
most oversubscribed class for employees
at Google recommended that I take a look
at loving-kindness meditation and and I
didn't have any particularly
sophisticated approach to it but I
decided with nothing to lose and that I
was having so much trouble during that
period sitting still and trying to focus
on say the breath or anything like that
that at night this was happened to
coincide with book deadline probably not
pure coincidence so that my beating
myself up was exacerbated during that
time that was a few years ago and I
began at night in my case in when I
would take a shower at night or sit in
I very often go to hotels to write which
is something Maya Angelou and a few
others that convinced me might be a good
idea that I would consider to people
just like you had mentioned to people I
really cared for and wish them well
that's all I did
and Jade had said to me mang is usually
what I would call him that at one point
a woman in one of his classes had done
this for one day at work every hour on
the hour she would just look out of her
office and wish someone well that she
could see in her mind's eye for 60
seconds or so and she says she said it
was her best day of work in seven years
and I found that unbelievable so I
decided to try it myself and that week
of just spending maybe two to four
minutes at night before going to bed
ended up being one of the most blissful
weeks in memory certainly at that point
in several years it was really profound
and I couldn't pick out any other
variable that had changed so for me I
just want to for people who are
listening and saying huh you know what
I'm type-a driven super hyper competitor
this doesn't apply to me that it very
well could apply to you and that by
taking a little bit of the harmful edge
off you don't automatically remove your
competitive edge and in fact I would
argue just as you mentioned that the
bowls and so on used to have or still do
it used to have a mindfulness coach for
competitive advantage that it can be
another tool in your toolkit and doesn't
take you out of the game so to speak it
just makes you more aware of the games
that you're playing so that's a long
sort of infomercial sales pitch that I
wanted to just make sure I got in
because I discounted a lot of these
practices for a very long time because I
thought it would at best be a waste of
time and at worse take away some of my
skills or tendencies that allowed me to
get to where I am so that that that is
more of a confessional than a question
but I would love to hear your thoughts
any additional thoughts on on
loving-kindness meditation but also any
additional thoughts on how if you wanted
to get a busy maybe even impatient
person hooked on mindfulness practice
what first steps or approaches you might
suggest so a lot of different questions
sort of woven into what you said and the
first is that there's a kind of
misunderstanding in our culture that
love is a weakness and it's not there is
a way in which it's the force that can
be probably the only force that can meet
the level of aggression or violence and
other such things that are happening in
you know in the world it's the power
that lets mothers lift cars off their
children or it'll let somebody like dr.
Martin Luther King stand you know after
his church was bombed and children were
killed and say we will meet your
physical violence with soul force we
will not harm you but we will love you
so deeply that we will not only
transform ourselves but we will
transform you in the process and so the
notion that love is somehow a weakness I
think we do everything out of love we
want to be loved even in our you know
ambition and our desire for for success
underneath it is you know we want to be
well we want to be find our happiness
and that's part of part of love so it's
it's actually a power and my colleague
and friend Weston ascore went to
interview Gary Snyder a couple of years
ago Gary is a Pulitzer Prize winning
poet and environmentalist for 50 years
when writing about bio regionalism and
one of our great kind of elders in this
environmental movement he said Gary what
do you have to say to us now that oceans
are rising the world climate is changing
you know hotter and hotter the species
extinction and gary looked back and he
said don't feel guilty if you're gonna
save it don't save it out of guilt or
anger or fear those are the very things
that are actually making the world worse
save it because you love it because it's
part of you because it met and that's
that that is the is the power whether
you're starting a company but also it's
not just that you you know some vision
okay now I'm going to become this
wealthy you know playboy or whatever you
know zillionaire then what is your life
mean for you and what do you really want
and when you listen there is something
in you and it's part of your birthright
to both be able to give your gifts but
also to love and be loved in return and
it turns out that it's a power so then
what you talk about is that it doesn't
take much to begin the training and
you're you know two minutes or four
minutes in the evening or this woman
that are work taking once an hour you
know 30 seconds or a minute to look at
somebody there and offer a well wishing
can transform everything for people who
want the practical support because it is
hard to do on your own if you go to
sounds true calm and look up the
programs that I have first there's a
forty day program called mindfulness
daily which is fifteen minutes a day or
twelve minutes a day depending on the
segment that both gives instructions in
mindfulness loving awareness and
loving-kindness practice and it's twelve
or fifteen minutes a day and by the end
of those forty days you really have
learned the inner skills and then it
builds up there's then a deeper training
called power of awareness and for those
who are interested we're about to open
an online teacher training for people
interested in mindful in in passing
along mindfulness and loving kindness to
others Jack just to interject for one
second for people listening I will also
link to all of these resources in the
show notes which you can find at tim dot
blog forward slash podcast so you don't
necessarily have to remember all these
things you can go to the URL and we will
have direct links to these resources
sorry to interrupt jack just wanted to
make sure our people listening and with
it then there is also of the programs
there there's one called guy
meditations that's you know a download
it's like 10 bucks or something and it
has a loving-kindness practice
compassion practice of forgiveness
practice I think it may even have a joy
practice and and so forth so you can and
it's really helpful to have guided
meditations at first because otherwise
your attention we have a very short
attention span in modern society Albert
Einstein at least according to
Scientific American said if you can
drive safely while kissing a girl you're
simply not giving the kiss the attention
it deserves and we are in this kind of
multitasking world with our devices and
and we've forgotten how to attend our
own hearts we've forgotten how in some
ways to really be present for one
another and more importantly for our own
life and so getting guided meditations
is tremendously helpful and doing these
little mini practices that you talked
about one minute two minutes several
times a day can transform you now I was
just gonna mention to people also if you
look at behavioural change if you look
at BJ Fogg formerly with the persuasion
laboratory at Stanford you look at diet
dietary change any of these things do
doing less than you think you're capable
of doing is a really good long-term
strategy in terms of starting off
rigging the game so that you can win in
the beginning so that your pass/fail
mark in your mind is a really really low
hurdle so I just wanted to reiterate
guided walk guided meditation don't
white-knuckle in the beginning like make
it bigger than easy as possible and the
same principle friend from the ancient
you know texts say that you start in the
easiest way for some people kindness for
themselves seems impossible but then you
pick a child you care about or someone
else or even when you do go to yourself
you think of yourself when you were an
innocent child and wish yourself well
the game is to do wear whatever
naturally opens the the Gateway
whatever's the easiest for some people
is their dog
holman you know the most non-judgmental
being in their life wags its tail and
loves you and it doesn't care you know
what's going on in your head so you take
the avenue that most naturally opens
your heart and then you do this just a
little at a time as you said and it
doesn't take long but the other thing
that's important is that sometimes as
you do it it can actually display or
show you the hyper critical nature of
your mind the shame that you carry and
the you know the self judgement or
self-loathing and so then you then you
say well what do you do then or it
brings it brings up its opposite is
that's the place that you just breathe
and hold all that stuff with thymus
because this is our humanity and we all
have some of that and the point isn't to
get rid of it or judge yourself for
having it or try to fix it it's almost
as if you put your hand on your heart
and you say you know this is like
mindful self-compassion of deep training
this is part of the measure of struggles
that I've been given like every human
being these things have tried to protect
me and now I can hold them with
tenderness and say all right you know
thank you but I don't need your help
anymore I can be kind to myself and and
and in that way you're not trying to fix
yourself or perfect yourself if anything
you're trying to perfect your love this
is Chuck I wanted to give you a credit
for help that you gave me and also
tactical advice that you gave me during
the 10-day silent retreat but you give
me a lot but I wanted to I want to
highlight one that's related to what you
just said I was going through a very
very difficult time particularly days 7
8 9 and you you gave me the advice that
you just mentioned and there's there's
one component I want to really
underscore for people and that is when
you're for instance trying to do
loving-kindness meditation and instead
you get the opposite or you get this
self ridicule who are you to try it to
meditate in this self-indulgent way this
is
this voice starts to pop up that is
angry or hateful whatever it might be
the process of not simply dismissing it
or fighting against it but recognizing
it as a coping strategy that helped you
in the past in some way that you
developed because in my case you know
the rage was a fuel that if I had it
without which I probably would never
have left Long Island where I had
friends who later overdosed on opiates
and so on so it was a gift in a way and
a tool and as you said you can thank
that response or that part of yourself
and then put it and I remember you
recommend it even visualizing and please
correct me if I'm wrong or elaborate but
visualize taking that part of you that
is a coping strategy thanking it and
then putting it say on a shelf where you
can use it later if need be
along with say other icons or figures
who whether it's Buddha or other that
that you recognizes wise and then
continuing with the meditation so that
thanking that part of yourself for the
function that it once served even if it
is not serving you now was such a key
insight for me that then helped me to
manage my internal states or observe and
appreciate my internal states for the
next several days where I really felt
like I was lost at that point so that
was a really direct tool that helped me
tremendously yeah thank you for bringing
it up because it's so important for
people when we come to that hyper
critical shame a shame place um we feel
very vulnerable and we've been
identified with it and because you
needed it I needed these things for
survival so and if you try to get rid of
this stuff you just end up in a
fruitless battle against yourself and
it's just more judgment so what you
described as saying thank you for
helping me survive I appreciate it let
me put it on the shelf or the altar I'll
put it in the lap of the Buddha or
whoever you know the goddess of infinite
you hold it for me if I need it I'll
pull it back and that sense that this
isn't who you are it doesn't describe
who you are it isn't who you are
it was it was a strategy because we're
vulnerable beings and you were tender as
a child you know and you had to make
sure you could survive thank you for
that and now I have a different capacity
and let me just talk about that capacity
a little bit because the capacity for
presence and the great heart of
compassion that's said to be your
birthright is a really mysterious thing
and talk about identity and when my
youngest brother's wife esta was dying
of cancer and she was just a beautiful
being and I spent quite a bit of time
with her and with my brother
I had gone home she was close to dying
I'd gone home to sleep and I want to get
up early and hurry back because it was
very close and I got my car I had to
stop at the drugstore to pick up a
prescription hurriedly running you know
dashing through the aisles and so forth
and I'm at the checkout counter and all
of a sudden my whole body relaxed and I
thought oh esta died and I got out to
the car and I called my brother I said
how's it going he said Oeste died a few
minutes ago and I said I know you know
I'll be there shortly and that we've all
had these experiences if I ask in a room
how many have had this particular kind
where you knew someone died when they
died you know a quarter of the hands
will go up why is this it's because who
we are is not this body we are we are
the consciousness itself and so with all
these practices what they allow us to do
is to step out of what's called the
small sense of self or the body of fear
and reconnect with the with a field of
connection of interdependence of
compassion and to
take our history and to honor it but not
be bound by it one of my favorite
stories is around us again the wonderful
spiritual teacher in the early years
when he came back from being with his
guru in India he was sitting up there
and teaching you know devotional
practices and meditation practices and
he had a beard and white robes and a and
and beads and he was sort of in the guru
outfit and a woman in the front row
raised her hand and say he robbed us
robbed us aren't you Jewish what's with
his Hindu stuff and Rhonda said well yes
I am actually I was bar Mitzvahed as as
I was - and there are many things I love
about the Jewish spiritual tradition the
generosity of it the the Kabbalah all
the great
you know teachings on the many stages
and states of consciousness the Hasidic
masters who are like Zen masters and
then he paused and looked at and he said
but remember I'm only Jewish on my
parents side and there is something both
witty which he was but also profound
about it because we are not just our
parental history or the historical
circumstances of this place and body
that we were born into and something in
us knows this so that when you look at
the there's a wonderful book that came
out last year the year before called the
book of joy which was a conversation
between the Dalai Lama and Archbishop
Tutu and both of them have marvelous
laughs I think people go to hear the
Dalai Lama by the tens of thousands not
just for the Tibetan teaching some of
which are actually hard to understand or
even the fact that he's this Nobel Prize
winning you know world figure I think
people go to hear him laugh that
somebody who's carried so much suffering
from the loss of his country where he
can't return and the burning of temples
and texts and all those things and he
had to - had a week together when they
were asked and took in this
in this book how can you be joyful how
can you laugh like this when you live
through apartheid and the death of so
many people around you then Dalai Lama I
mean they they banter back and forth
them like brothers and Allah missus so
much has been taken from me you know
they've taken our sacred texts they've
taken our ability to make prayers in
public they've taken you know so much of
our culture why should I let them take
my happiness and then to to starts to
laugh and giggle and say you know I've
been through so much but I am NOT going
to let myself live in that place I'm
gonna let myself live in that which
affirms life and in a kind of profound
joy that we made it that we're still
alive that we can contribute that we can
be here in this beautiful earth and this
shift of consciousness is what's needed
for the world because if we look
honestly no amount of technology alone
is going to save us nanotechnology and
space technology and biotechnology and
world-wide-web internet computer or
supercomputer technology is going to
stop continuing warfare and racism and
tribalism and environmental destruction
those are happening based on
consciousness of the human heart and so
we are now you know these you've made
these enormous developments outwardly
where you have the Great Library of
Alexandria and your smartphone in your
pocket along with a million you know cat
youtubes or whatever but there it is
it's all in there and then what we need
is collectively to develop a
transformation inwardly of our inner
life that is parallel to this enormous
outer transformation and that's not you
know one of the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff some years ago said we
are a nation of nuclear giants and
ethical infants
you know how old i don't know how old
you manatee is but it's time you know
it's time to grow up so so that this
this work that we're talking about is
both individual but as you learn to meet
your own life with greater understanding
and compassion it empowers you to move
through the world in a different way and
to help others do the same and then you
get the kind of joy of tutu in the Dalai
Lama that you're somehow part of an
awakening that humanity now needs more
than ever Jack I'd love to ask you and
these interviews are always driven by
some self-interest I always have
something issue or challenge or problem
that I'm trying to figure out so I
reached out to someone like you to help
me do it but I record the conversation
as we chatted about before we hit record
and you know this already but the last
several years have been very very
important for me in terms of addressing
certain traumas and the last eight weeks
in particular have been transformative
in a lot of beautiful ways and the
periods the the duration of periods
within which I don't berate or attack
myself have become longer but there are
still times when the wheels fly off the
car and this last week has been one such
example and I tend to when I make a
mistake or feel like I'm backsliding or
relapsing to compound the problem by
beating myself up which then I start to
then I beat myself up about beating
myself up and you know where that goes
so let me paint a picture so I found out
recently that my Japanese host father
and I've been in touch with this family
since I was 15 I'm very very close to
them 40 now and I found out that he just
was admitted because the host mother
sent me an email to the hospital with
liver cancer and this there they don't
have the details yet I just sent a
follow-up email they don't know what the
prognosis is exactly but
in needless to say the worst-case
scenarios are certainly being conjured
in my mind or the potential of those and
then simultaneously have been contending
with and I believe you have some
experience with this contending with a
what should be a very simple
construction project of a cabin up in
the mountains and it is it has been
delayed and delayed and delayed and
there have been cost overruns and cost
overruns it cost overruns and promises
made promises broke and expectations set
expectations missed and a friend of mine
called with a whole new slew of problems
yesterday related to this place and I
lost my for lack of a better term I
mean there there are many other things
going on simultaneously but I got really
pissed I was like you know what this
extending the olive branch being
understanding can't gambit is not
working with these people like I need I
need I need to take out the baseball bat
and like pull old Tim off the shelf who
was just this like juggernaut head
through brick walls and be like listen
like if you don't do ABCD and E
here well these are gonna be the
consequences and then I'm like well wait
I'm supposed to be compassionate but how
do I not be a pushover and it turns into
this big dramatic play inside my head
and then I wait then this is gonna end
soon I'm not going to keep going but
what I then often do is self-medicate
with caffeine and I think it's a way of
feeling productive without actually
being productive and it also creates so
much volume on the noise I think I use
it to tune out a lot of feelings so when
someone relapse is there has this kind
of experience what do you suggest to
them I mean is there is there a
particular pattern interrupt or approach
that you've found helpful for regaining
footing oh so there's a number of things
to say yeah first of all you could call
it relapsing or you could just call it
like yeah this is being human
the put one of the PO the most most
beloved poet in Japan was a Zen master
named ryokan and there's a two line
verse that of his that I particularly
find fitting for this where he wrote
last year a foolish monk this year no
change you know and you can sort of feel
the humor and the tenderness in it
and and there's a way in which you see
your personality the point you know you
have a body you have this particular
body or bonus and you can transform it
in certain ways within the limits of the
body that you were given and similarly
you have a personality and anybody who
has a number of kids realizes that you
don't come in tabula rasa that you
actually this kid is born it has this
kind of temperament so you have
personality and just like you don't want
to look too closely to the BA at the
body sometimes you don't look back
closely the personality either you know
it has its foibles and its fears and you
know all of that and so you start to
kind of look at and say oh now there's a
really good example of how neurotic I
can get thank you thank you for
reminding me you know and then you get a
little sort of like the keeper of the
zoo a little more tender with this those
kind of creatures so that's that's it's
bringing in the non judgment you know or
the loving-kindness for the way that you
actually are and not your ideal or
bringing compassion you could say yeah
this is a tough one in this triggered I
got triggered so what now the other
thing is that I have the same experience
we had a big remodel of our house when I
was some years ago and raising my
daughter and and in my first marriage
and we were supposed to go and teach and
travel in Europe and this guy who was a
good contractor but you know everything
of course gets more expensive in you
knew this and it kept getting slowed
down I said you were gonna get this done
so we could make these decisions go into
Europe and it's not happening you've
gotta hurry up I do that like three or
four different times and it doesn't
happen finally I go in I get pissed and
I say listen you know you said
our contract was gonna be done by and if
you don't get this done by the
time I'm gonna haul your ass in court
didn't sue you because I I need this
done and I'm not gonna pay you the
goddamn money although he looked at me
and he said oh you really want this done
don't you yes next day there's a huge
crew it starts to katella I realized
okay what I've been sort of talking
meditation speak yeah a nice get it done
he was a contractor and I just
had to peek I had to speak contractor
ease get the goddamn job done or I'll
haul your ass okay I get it yeah I'll
send the team over and that's all it
took so but there's something playful
about that as well it's not that you
can't
I've seen the die llama get angry at
people it's not that you can't use that
power and that understanding you know
when it's necessary to get to be very
strong or forceful and you don't have to
judge yourself unless you hurt people
and then of course that's the misuse of
it but it's just it's part of being
human is there something you say to
yourself when no I think I don't know
you are certainly in person and any with
any contact I've had of you with you one
of the most compassionate people I've
ever met and I don't use that word very
much but your your presence of listening
and being with someone is really
incredible and I don't know how much of
that is an intrinsic versus trained but
for better for worse you're coming out
of the womb I've been very impatient
since day one so I worry about I can get
my it seems like my default is the yell
is is speaking contractor ease to more
than just the the way word contractor is
yeah I was putting off work is there
some when I feel that the sensations of
anger beginning to bubble up is there
something
that you would suggest as self-talk or
just a temporary pumping of the brakes
to make it an informed decision versus
just a lashing out well I could give you
an answer but in a minute I'm gonna
guide you in a little practice perfect
so that you can find that find the
better answer first I just want to say
that um that anger you know yes it's
your habit or maybe your temperament
that's energy and there's nothing wrong
with energy you know it's it's the power
that let you do all the kind of things
you've done in your life that are
tremendously you know creative or
resourceful or daring or whatever kinds
of things so you want to respect okay
I'm getting filled with energy and and
you you know might be and then you want
to lash out but first you want to
respect that energy Wow let me feel this
in my buddy who anger how big is it move
okay then your question is then your
question is what can I do to modulate it
I could give you you know okay take some
breaths ground yourself look at that
other person remember but instead as
we're talking let yourself picture a
circumstance recently it might have been
with your you know the contractor is
doing your cabin or something else and
you're you know that uprising of the
injustice of it and how right you are
you know and how you're gonna get this
goddamn thing done you know and how you
have to have to be hard and strong you
feel all that and feel that energy in
your body first thing is just to
remember what it felt like and now
you're becoming the the kind of mindful
loving witness of it and saying wow this
is a lot of energy can you feel that and
remember that oh yeah okay now next step
is that the wisest you know figure you
can imagine maybe it's the Buddha or or
maybe it's I don't know it doesn't
doesn't matter some great master martial
arts master you know who's mastered
themselves as well as there are comes to
you and let yourself imagined
somebody's gonna teach you how to manage
this powerful energy and see who appears
somebody appears to you mm-hmm and first
they look at you and they smile and they
say yeah this is really this is the big
energy and they appreciate you so
instead of saying oh you're a doofus
you know they say oh yeah you actually
you actually carry some powerful energy
and they acknowledge that they bow to
you yeah Tim you got it all right and
then you say yeah but how do I manage
this when it takes me over
and so this send master or whoever comes
reaches under their robe and pulls out a
gift for you which is a clear symbol of
exactly what you need in that moment to
help you regulate it so that you can
keep the energy but do it in a way that
doesn't cause harm to you or another and
this clear symbol you'll be able to see
it's just what you need so let yourself
picture the gift that they put in your
hand and let yourself imagine see
envision picture what it what it is and
if you can't see it clearly hold it up
to the sunlight you'll be able to and
then let me know what you get you want
me to tell you what it is yeah yeah all
right
so the person who came to mind for me I
went through a few was the creator of
Judo fast know a guy named Igor
O'Connell really saw a small guy who yes
who could who could throw all the big
guys and smile at the same time right
exactly changed a lot also in Japanese
government fascinating guy lease the
symbol I don't know why this is to be
honest but it's a pyramid the size was
with straight edges about a little too
big to hold in your palm that is blue
it's like a almost a mixture of Scot
pure sky-blue like blue bird blue with a
bit of electric blue mixed in and it's
sort of a smoky
that's floating around inside this glass
pyramid I've no idea why that's the case
but that's what came up alright so we'll
stay with it and then there's one more
little piece so he gives you this this
pyramid free-associate a little bit on
here what it might possibly mean because
these symbols are like dream images and
they have they come from a deep place in
your psyche and this pyramid has a
message for you this blue pyramid just
guess what it might be I think it's very
very stable it's a little stream least
stable structure and for me it also I
could imagine it representing power also
it seems like a very powerful symbol in
many different cultures certainly yeah
the blue the blue is a little easier for
me it's a very cooling soothing color
we're certainly red is the the colour of
especially with a fire with the right
the high resonance anger energy would be
more of a red fire element so the blue
would be a cooling or countering
balancing force for that all right so
now what I want you to do is imagine
taking this blue pyramid gift which
represents a kind of extreme stability
and also a kind of power and cooling
that's given to you by Chicago Cano and
taking this into your body so that there
you are filled with this energy and
anger you know you've this huge wave of
if you'd let that be there and you take
this pyramid in and you let that energy
be inside this stable grounded place of
power and feel what it's like to be
inside this blue pyramid with this
energy and feel how it to feel how it
affects it just notice as if there
you're in that circumstance and now I'm
remembering I am the blue pyramid with
the and what do you you know what is if
you like
life that the most noticeable thing and
you know I wonder of course how much of
this is the the actual visualization
versus the timeout right I permit myself
to have but there's a there's very often
a tightness on the left side of my chest
right by the sternum what I feel when I
start getting wound up that is absent
when after taking this gift and then
visualizing it being incorporated so
that's what you what you're practicing
you know and you know this very well in
athletics that yes you practice things
but other times you also practice
envisioning whether it's playing piano
or whether it's you know some some
Olympic training that some of the times
you just do it
and through visualization and it
activates a lot of the same neural
circuitry so here you're starting to get
the feeling of what it's like to be in
the middle of this upwelling of anger
and so forth and then taking a couple of
breaths and feeling the blue pyramid and
the connection with the earth and the
stability of it and the power then of
that presence that cools you and allows
the anger to be there but not in the
same uncontrolled way now there's one
more thing and that is if you imagine
again you got okano I believe you said
it's Navis you got it he comes he comes
up to you after giving you this gift and
he touches you kindly on the shoulder
and he has a few words of advice of how
to handle this powerful energy that
comes up in you because he knows all
about it and what does he whisper into
your ear
kaalia well he whispers this this this
came to mind immediately
he says Zen yoga zaniel which is you
know I still have this actually there
too he has many famous quotes but he has
what you might consider proverbs short
aphorisms that I I've actually carried
with me since I was fifteen but
they're pack oh they're packed away
somewhere I have two of them they're on
cloth and the the first is still me
about stole made a buck cannot other
thoughts though it's means basically if
you if you work hard you will achieve
you will reach your your target it's not
the best translation but that's the idea
the other one is Zen neo cuisine you'll
which is effectively the most efficient
use of energy but it could also be the
best / most benevolent use of energy and
it's it's a principle of Judo but it's
something that he applied to everything
includes including education so it would
be that very short bite-sized aphorism
which is and I'm sure some scholars
probably disagree with me but roughly
translated here at least as I take it is
the maximum or most efficient use of
energy so take that in take his his
intentions oh and Zen Yoko's nu the
benevolent and efficient use of it
feel the pyramid and now your assignment
is that the next five times that this
comes which it will maybe tomorrow or
next week or so forth bringing the blue
pyramid stable powerful cooling so the
energy still there and then you hear his
voice
stays in yoko xin yo and you go oh yeah
i can use this but i can use it in a
benevolent way and try it five times and
then then text me let me know what
happened because that we're closing the
loop if you do it and see now you've now
you're responsible if you agree that
you're gonna do it it's sort of goose it
gooses the game a little bit you go okay
no i better do it because i have to let
Jax know whoever you know what happened
and let me know what happened
well i'll be able to i'll be able to use
it this week because i'm flying out to
the site of this cabin to meet with
everybody and see what that so i'll have
at least five opportunities to do that
i mean the other thing that it's it's
great and then that you can hear in this
rather than by giving you a cookie
cutter answer is that we actually have
the wisdom that were seeking or that's
available we have it in ourselves I mean
you didn't have to fly to you know Kyoto
and getting your time machine to go back
and see you go to hell you know or
whoever it happens to be the Dalai Lama
or whoever happens to come to you the
Buddha or some other great figure that
actually the goddess of compassion that
we carry that wisdom in our own heart
and part of what these contemplative
trainings do is they give us access just
by taking a little pause it didn't take
you 30 seconds okay he appears what do i
do oh here's how my body would feel what
what perspective should I bring ah
here's efficient and benevolent use of
energy okay now I remember
so these answers for the for the
questions of the psyche in the heart
don't require going somewhere they asked
us to quiet and begin to listen and as
you do then you discover your own in
your own inherent wisdom and your own
compassion as well because the the
benevolent use that he offers to you
where does that live it lives in him it
lives in you this is one of the one of
the reasons I've wanted to have you on
the podcast for so long is that for me
you represent a very wide spectrum of
tools you have developed toolkit that it
has enabled you to work with everyone
from the that the seekers of say the
Buddhists along the lines of the
Buddhist traditions to say adolescents
are cutters to war vets with PTSD
missing limbs and so on you've worked
with a very diverse set of students and
patients maybe even and that leads me to
my next question which is after these
experiences abroad
why did you decide
to pursue to come back why do you decide
to come back to the u.s. period and then
why did you decide to go back to school
and study clinical psychology so um
after the first five years in Asia there
were a certain there were a few other
Westerners who would become monks it was
a handful and some were gonna stay for
the rest of their lives I'd learned a
lot and so that was kind of a choice am
I'm just gonna stay and I realized no I
want a family I want to love her you
know I was a young man after all in just
the celibacy for those years was
actually pretty hard I want I want to
see if what I have learned really
translates into the life back home I
don't want to just leave it and so I was
some wrestling but it became very clear
to me that I that I wasn't fit for the
monastery for the rest of my life I had
other not only other desires but also
and longings but also were real interest
to say does this work elsewhere so I
came back I thought well what can I do I
got it got a couple jobs and right away
and of course what I knew how to do is
be a student but I was now a student of
the mind in the heart and I thought well
how do I learn more about what happened
to me in the monastery
oh I'll study Western psychology and so
that started me on that particular path
and I learned a lot of complimentary
things there's some very good trauma
work in the West that I've learned about
that really enhances the compassion and
loving-kindness and mindfulness things
that I learned in in the temple and you
know now I've done a lot of years of
teaching Eastern Western psychology
together these principles that I've
learned are spreading so widely in
Western psychology I went to the largest
therapy conference in in the country in
December and down in Anaheim and gave a
talk and you know here's a roomful of
3,000 or 5,000 people and I asked how
many of you have
some experience of meditation or
mindfulness practice and the majority of
the hands went up and that would not
have happened you know 20 or 30 years
ago so the eastern psychology is now
becoming more invisibly woven into the
understandings of clinical psychology
and the rest and it's beautiful now I
want to say something else you know when
you talk about working with a variety of
population you know
yes people in prisons yes that's kids
coming out of gangs but also um CEOs and
there's a a dialogue that built for it
and I did use that that time the
chairman of Ford Motors he was actually
the CEO perhaps before that but name is
he's the chairman of Ford Motors and he
talks about it too it was in 2008 I
guess when the auto industry was just
about to melt down and he called we'd
had some contact he's a meditator and he
said you know I'm gonna lose the my
grandfather's company maybe the whole
industry on my watch and it's hard to
sleep what can I do and we did
loving-kindness practices and and
mindfulness practices together and so
forth and I gave him some practices that
he could use and it turns out that at
whatever level you're on whether you're
incarcerated or whether you're a CEO or
whether you're returning that that these
inner capacities that we have to be
present without getting lost to bring a
an understanding attention to these
energies just as you were doing with
anger in ourselves are really really
liberating and sometimes you know what's
needed like for the vets or the the
people coming back from the war is also
a kind of forgiveness practice in trauma
work and we'll come together and you
know they'll say things like
I can't tell you what I saw because in
fact people don't want to hear the
horrors of war they can't tell the story
and if they do often they reach Ramat
eyes themselves and the people around
them couldn't bear it but there's
something worse because they'll say I
can't tell you what I had to do and so
it's locked up in their hearts you know
and then what do they have they can
drink or they can you know distract
themselves or get in you know blind
rages periodically but if you get a room
of returning combat vets and hold it
with a proper space of understanding and
compassion not only can they tell their
stories which they've never told but
they can listen to one another and say
oh yeah I've been there and all of a
sudden they're not so alone anymore and
and that release of the weight on their
heart so there's a social dimension to
trauma where we need to tell the story
helps them release also what's carried
in their nervous system and in their
body and there's some some correlation
between between those two together that
becomes very powerful and we need that
we need I do a lot of teaching of
forgiveness practice and self
forgiveness those are also on those
those guided meditations that I teach
and for a lot of us self forgiveness
like self compassion becomes a very very
important way to liberate ourselves from
what we had to do to survive in the past
so that we're actually free in our life
how do you set the stage for instance
with those with those vets what do you
say to them or what what exercise might
you do that opens a door for them so are
these stories so a couple of images one
with gang kids and then one with vets
for for gang kids who come in or these
kids who are trying to get out of gangs
and might come with a mentor or
something like that to some events we've
had you can get these guys and they're
you know they're their hoods are up and
their hats around backward and they're
lean back and saying like come on man
you're gonna teach us meditation you're
gonna teach us give us some poem stories
or a bit this is bad we're out on the
street people got nine-millimeters you
know you got to give us something better
than that so we try to make a setting
that honors who they are from the very
beginning or say well we can't talk yet
about the real things that we came here
to do because there are too many people
in this room who have not been
acknowledged and not in the respected so
would you go out in the parking lot and
pick up a stone for every young person
you know who's been killed and we light
one candle and put it on the center of a
table say bring it back in and say their
name and put their stone by this candle
the simplest possible ritual and these
guys and sometimes gals will come in and
their hands are full of stones no young
people should know that many dead people
and and they'll say this is for Tito and
this is for RJ and this is for homegirl
and pretty soon there's a mound of
stones and the names of people they've
lost we're put into the the fabric of
the air of that room and their hoods are
no longer over their head so they're
sitting up like okay this is a place
where we can talk about what's really
going on so there's something about
making whether it's through as the
simplest ritual or making a container in
which people realize that this is a safe
place to talk about what we've never
done before with the vets one of the
things that Michael Mead Louisa
Rodriguez these guys from mosaic multi
cultural foundation that I've worked
with for years and are really wonderful
Michael who's a you know a great drummer
and a storyteller and mythologist who's
also been working in prisons and with
vets and gang kids for years he'll say
let me tell you an ancient story of
returning
careers and he has a handful of stories
from Africa or to bad or the Mayan
tradition about warriors coming back you
know with their hands covered with blood
and you know their eye is filled with
the the Mars with a martial energy that
they would that they can't stop the
violence because it's taken them over
and here's a myth or a story that tells
about how ancient warriors were brought
back into their community I'll tell you
the myth if you want to hear one of them
oh yes please
so here we are you know and there's
these there's these vets and already
stories have started to pour out about I
can't tell you what I saw I can't tell
you what I had to do and Michael stood
up and he said let me tell you an old
Irish story of a an Irish warrior named
Coco Lane or I'm not sure how his name
is pronounced something like that and he
was the most fierce and famous of all
Irish warriors and the Irish warriors
were were mad men because they would go
out they paint their bodies and then go
out naked and sometimes you just see
them coming and you'd run the other way
but anyway there was some rotting King
King King and army that had come to
threaten their area and so kuku Lane
went out and almost single-handedly
chased them and defeated them but then
he was coming back to his own town in a
chariot covered with blood and his eyes
blazing bearing down on his own town
still possessed with the violence of war
with the god Mars and they were all
terrified he would come and do violence
there too and so they round what can we
do what can we do and they went to ask
the old wise woman in the village and
she said three things and so the first
thing they lined up all the women in the
village who bared their breasts and this
slowed him down as if it reminded him of
his mother's milk course
thing and because he was slowed down and
the second thing they did was take a
rope and tie it around him and put him
in a huge cauldron of cold water which
hissed off his body and then they filled
it three times with cold water and
finding his body cooled down and then
the third thing they did is they took
him at still bound and they lay him on a
carpet in the court of the local King
and they sang to him the stories and
myths and songs of warriors who had
protected the kingdom and then come back
and released the violence and the fears
that they carried and planted their
crops again and loved their families and
resumed living in harmony with the
community from which they came and they
told the ancient stories and sang the
songs for three days and nights and when
it was over cuckoo cuckoo laying eyes
opened they let his they untied him and
he was back as a normal human being
again and after Michael told this story
to vets who've been telling and terrible
accounts of things that happened in this
room
a hundred men stood up and we'd been
working with a simple African chant a
song that was really an African chant of
a prayer you know earth hold me for this
living is hard we all sang to the vets
together for a long time as if we could
sing them back into their bodies from
this as if they were lying there in the
court of the King so this is and you ask
the question how do you how do you make
a setting that allows people to truly
feel that they can tell their stories
and be held in compassion whether it's
the grief of these gang kids that no
one's really given them the place to
give voice to you know or the vet who
says I can't tell you what I had to do
that's very powerful and it makes me
also think back to conversations I've
had with Sebastian Junger who was a
wartime journalist as co-produced and
shot a number of really hiring
documentary films including Restrepo and
most recently wrote a book called tribe
that touches on some similar topic area
and leads me to ask you are there any
rites of passages or rituals that you
feel would be useful for every man or
woman to experience
infra and this is something that I've
felt a longing for and a lack of since
my teenage years because I I'm not
Jewish did not have a bat mitzvah Bar
Mitzvah I don't know if that serves that
purpose in the in the Jewish tradition
necessarily but are there any any
rituals or rites of passage that you
think we could use in let's just say the
United States that would be helpful to
whether it's a specific population
specific group or anyone so what you're
talking about is a really big subject at
the subject of initiation and
unfortunately bar mitzvahs at least when
I was in where as was a relatively
lightweight and meaningless thing you
get up there and you recite your you
know Hebrew portion of the Bible and now
you're a man and they give you a bunch
of presents and there wasn't a lot of
meaning in it but the problem that you
raise is that of the lack of initiation
and what's true is that it's been
forgotten in our culture one of the few
places you get initiation is going into
the military that's not initiation but a
lot of these gang kids for example
they're trying to initiate themselves
which can't really happen you need
elders and you need it in a ritualized
way
don't go on that you know if you're in
the Masai tradition in East Africa the
Maasai people as everybody's heard you
know a young man at a certain age of
fourteen or something will go out and
kill a lion to prove that they're now an
adult member of the society and that
they're brave and that's part of their
initiation of their initiations for
young women as well and it's not just in
Africa the Mayans had initiations and in
Thailand when I lived there back
starting in the 1960s at that point
almost every young man and many young
women when they reached the age of 1920
they became a monk for three months or
for a year
and lived in an austere way and it was
part of their initiation to learn both
the inner life of themselves and also a
kind of discipline we don't have it and
because of it
you know kids are trying to initiate
themselves on the streets by you know
shooting somebody or doing something you
know that shows that they're brave but
it's not a lion it's another person or
it's you know trying to get the
attention of the others and say prove
how how powerful or strong they are so
we desperately need these and we need
them built into our education and to our
psychology and I can't give you a simple
answer but one of the people who has the
most intelligence about this is a man a
colleague of mine named Michael Mead and
if you look at mosaic multicultural
foundation his writings on initiation
and what's possible here and the things
he's led are very very inspiring so
that's a place that I would look that's
a good starting point wonderful I will
certainly find that well Jack I think we
could go for hours and hours and hours
and I always love chatting with you and
I'd love to perhaps even consider doing
a part two sometime but given that we've
already gone for two-plus hours I want
to ask just a few more questions and
I'll actually start with just reading
something very short which is from your
year end message and it says I think
this is just to inject some more
optimism into our conversation which
we've already had plenty of but this is
this is just a small portion of your
urine message Martin Luther King jr.
describes our collective journey with
hope quote the arc of the moral universe
is long but it bends towards justice end
quote and Pablo Neruda explains further
you can cut all the flowers but you
cannot keep spring from coming renewal
is happening this is back to your voice
take quiet time to listen to your heart
to meditate and to rest amidst the great
turnings feel the renewal of spring that
can be born in you align yourself with
goodness let yourself blossom like a
lotus or whatever unique flower you are
shining in the world offering tiny seeds
of love amidst it all blessings to you
in 2018 Jack and I
I want this this note to then lead into
and certainly welcome to comment on that
but which book you would recommend of
yours people start with or where they
start with all of the many materials
recordings readings that you produce
because you're a a fantastic writer and
a prolific writer you have some of my
favorite book titles I've ever heard by
the way including after the ecstasy the
laundry which maybe we could touch on
but where would you suggest people start
of the many things that you've that
you've written and shared with the world
and and if you have any comments on that
year-end message you're welcome to share
that as well so for books if you want
something simple I have books like you
know an introduction to meditation that
sounds true publishes or I have a little
book called the art of forgiveness
loving-kindness and peace which is very
simple stories and practices if you want
something that's richer and fuller then
you could look at one of my bigger books
like a path with heart or the wise heart
the guide to the two principles of
Buddhist psychology and again I think
lots of stuff online and sounds trues
particularly a good place to go along
with my website then and that 40 day
mindfulness mindfulness daily which is
like it's like 30 bucks or something in
you you know is a really wonderful way
to start in terms of what I had written
about the trusting heart one of the
greatest Zen texts from thousand years
ago says to be awakened or enlightened
is one with the trusting heart and mind
and that doesn't mean that that we won't
go through hard times we always have and
we will again and we are now in many
ways but that we also have born within
us the capacity to meet these
difficulties with understanding and with
courage with compassion and to transform
them and in that way one of my favorite
recent books is called the better angels
of our nature by Steven Pinker and he's
a remarkable you know professor at
Harvard an apologist historian talking
about the growing consciousness of
humanity in spite of the kind of wars in
conflict and environmental things there
are so many good things that have
happened that he charts over the last
few centuries of the development of you
know certain certain abilities for
peacemaking there's actually less war
than there'd been the you know respect
for for women the reduction in you know
child labor all kinds of things and and
in that same regard there's a wonderful
book called bury the chains which is
about the ending of slavery in the
British Empire starting with this
handful of men who met in a British tea
shop or printing shop and spent 30 years
riding around the country bringing ex
slaves who were well spoken to talk
about the Middle Passage and that you
know the horrors of slavery and so forth
and even though the British Empire's
economic engine was built around slavery
and sugar by the end of their work
thirty years that the British Parliament
come out one slavery in the British
Empire it's you know decades before it
happened in the US and the Quakers were
a big part of this and the Quakers
famously wouldn't take their hats off
for the king but when what is his name
Thomas Clarkson who was the center of
this group trying to end slavery and
going everywhere to do it when Thomas
Clarkson died that all the Quakers of
the England England took their hats off
because he heeds freed so many spirits
in so many lives so the possible we have
these amazing possibilities as human
beings and we're just growing into them
now culturally and it's about time but
it's it but there they are possible and
we each have a have a contribution to
make in it Jack I'm gonna ask you one
more question before we wrap up with
just letting people know where they can
find you on social media and elsewhere
on the website and so on but last
question is one I like to ask and this
is this is a metaphor but if you could
have a short message on a billboard in
other words get them get a message out
to millions or billions of people it
could be a few words one word a phrase a
quote of yours a quote of someone else's
what might you put on that billboard
well two things come to mind one is a
question that when I sit with sat with
people many times at the end of their
life that they that they then ask of
themselves silently or aloud is did I
love well because in the end what
matters really well the Billboard would
have a question rather than a statement
and it would have a question something
like how could I love myself better or
what you know so that it actually it's
not that I'm gonna tell them
something they already know this but I'm
gonna remind those who read that there
is something that's asking to be
awakened in them how could I love myself
and this world better and then you know
or what gets and you know then you go
what gets in the way of that and how
could I love that too how could I love
myself in this world better hmm
well Jack I want to of course thank you
for your time today but beyond that I
want to thank you and this is this is
very very much from deep in my heart
thank you for helping me to learn to
love myself better and quite frankly to
see something in the first place that is
worth loving that's not where I've spent
most of my life so it's turned into if
not my I hesitate to say my top priority
because I'm worried about sounding it
self-indulgent but it's become one of
the most important and fruitful tasks in
my life is asking that question how
could I love myself better or how could
I learn to love myself better so thank
you very very sincerely for that and
that the words don't do it justice but
that's all that's the best I can do
right now remotely is to is to put it
into words so thank you for that thank
you Tim this was this was a pleasure to
do and what I feel and I know is it as
you tend your own heart I'm in a wise
way then it makes you available to bring
the gifts the many gifts you have to the
world you personally and others but to
do it in a way that's on the carrier
wave of connection and love and it
transforms everything so thank you -
well Jack I you know I'm looking at a
text thread of ours and I'm feeling the
necklace around my neck which is really
a thread a red phone that was used to
close the one of the elements of the
closing of the 10-day silent retreat and
I shot you a text not too long ago
asking what the three knots meant
because I'd forgotten and this is what
you wrote back
first not equals refuge in whatever you
hold is most inspiring and sacred second
commitment to compassion for self and
others third following your highest
intention and the intention that I've
set at the end of that ten day retreat
was to learn to love myself so I could
love others more fully but I realized
that maybe what it is is learning to
love myself so I can help others learn
to do the same and you've been an
integral piece of that and I just love
that I have the opportunity to introduce
you and your work and these traditions
to more people and I will certainly be
linking to where everyone can find you
online but are there any particular best
places just to reiterate where people
can find you and I'll link to these in
the show notes jack Kornfield comm and
also look up jack Kornfield on sounds
true comm for those programs that I
talked about and then spirit Rock org
which is our great Meditation Center in
the Bay San Francisco Bay Area
absolutely stunning stunning beautiful
vacation worth visiting just to bathe in
the scenery but many more reasons to to
visit as well well Jack thank you again
and thank you thank you Tim it's a
pleasure and to everybody listening you
can find show notes links to all the
resources books and everything that we
discussed at Tim blog for slash podcast
and until next time thank you so much
for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird that have
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll
spell out and just drop in if your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by fresh books
man oh man do a lot of listeners to the
podcast and readers of mine love fresh
books to the extent that I ended up
meeting with the CEO not very long ago
why are they so popular well they are
the number one cloud accounting software
designed exclusively for self-employed
professionals that's many of you and
used by more than 10 million people you
can send invoices track your time and
get paid very very quickly which suits
the needs of a lot of freelancers are
lots of Pontifex lender loose and beyond
you can take pictures of receipts you
can link your credit cards and debit
cards so all the things you buy
automatically appear in your fresh books
in the right category so on and so forth
makes taxes easy makes invoices easy
makes your life easier
and also in fact I recommend a PDF they
didn't ask me to read this part by the
way they put the other PDF a while back
called breaking the time barrier
subtitle how to unlock your true earning
potential so you can search for breaking
the time barrier a lot of people ask me
how can I get a 4-hour workweek with the
service business and the story in that
ebook its PDF is the short answer it's
really really good so I think you should
also check that out so breaking the time
error check it out but also why not test
out fresh books claim your 30-day
unrestricted free trial at fresh
ebooks.com forward slash tim and enter
tim ferriss two hours in two S's in the
how did you hear about us section that
sounds like we're gonna get very little
tracking that's a lot of work but just
go to fresh books comm forward slash tim
and try it out because it is a very good
product and i think you will find it
simplifies your life enjoy this episode
is brought to you by four sig Matic you
might remember for sig Matic for their
mushroom coffee which was created by
those clever Finnish founders and when I
first mentioned that coffee on this
podcast the products sold out in less
than a week it lights you up like a
Christmas tree which can be really
useful however recently I've been
testing the opposite side of the
spectrum a new product and that is their
reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my
day to get to sleep as you guys may know
longtime listeners at least I struggled
with insomnia for decades I've a largely
fixed that but still shutting off my
monkey brain has never been easy still
isn't easy very often and I found reishi
which have been fascinated by for a few
years now has been very very effective
and calming their old formula however
for sig Maddox old formula included
stevia and I like to avoid sweeteners
all sweeteners for a host of reasons and
I then just ping them and asked hey guys
I would love to experiment with this and
maybe actually suggest it but I'd like a
version without sweeteners if you'd be
open to it too much of headache don't
worry
and they are always game for
experimentation and so they created a
special custom version without the
stevia without sweeteners now it is part
of my nightly routine their ratio elixir
comes in single serving packets which
are perfect for travel and in fact I'm
about to leave the country right now and
I have a packet in front of me that's
just gonna sit in the end of my carry-on
bag
you only need hot one and it mixes very
very easily here's some recommended copy
that they put in the read so I'm gonna
read it and I'll give you my take quote
a warning for those in the experimental
mindset reishi is strong and bitter in
parentheses like any great medicine so
if the bitterness is too much I
recommend trying it with honey and or
nut milk such as almond milk and quote
so I'm gonna say no you should suck it
up and you should drink the tea because
it's not that bitter and maybe should
take the advice of all Chinese people
when they're criticizing youngins when
they say boo and I'm sure it cool which
means you're not able to eat bitterness
bitter is in many cases an indication of
things that help liver detoxification
and so on not saying that's the case
here but I've tested this ratio chert on
family members on friends everybody has
liked it it's a little bit earthy it's
not that hard so I would just say suck
it up and know don't put in honey or nut
milk or any of that just drink the
goddamn tea it's delicious I think if
you like to err that kind of stuff that
type of tea you're gonna dig it so just
try it okay back to then my read if
you'd like to naturally improve your
sleep both on set and quality I think
naturally you might just enjoy this
ratio lecture without any sweeteners it
has organic reishi extract organic field
mint extract organic rosehips extract
organic Tulsi extract and that's it no
fancy stuff no artificial
whatchamacallit anything so check it out
go to for stigmatic comport slash
ferrous and get 20% off this special
batch I don't know if they're gonna be
making much more of this since it was
made specifically for you guys so do me
a favor and try it out so that they
continue to be open to experimenting
with me to create products for
you guys specifically check it out for
sick at matok that's fo you are SI g ma
TI c calm for Sasha Ferris f e RR ISS
and get 20% off the special batch and
you must use the code Ferris to receive
a discount fer are ISS so again go to 4
Sigma to calm forward slash Ferris and
then use code Ferris for 20% off of this
rare exclusive limited run of reishi
mushroom elixir for night time routines
without any sweeteners enjoy
[Applause]